pour rendre la discussion et le débat me
semble-t-il plus intelligible monsieur
le président il n'y a pas d'opposition
je n'en vois pas donc il en est ainsi
décidé
donc des articles additionnels avant
l'article 1er le premier 254 madame
brûlant
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre cet amendement nous proposons
que le gouvernement rende un rapport
avant même la mise en oeuvre du texte
que nous sommes en train d'examiner pour
faire un point sur
les bénéfices ou non de la mise en
oeuvre du pass sanitaires on voit bien
que le sujet qui est le nôtre
aujourd'hui c'est que le vaccin protège
notamment des formes les plus graves du
coc vide mais n'empêche pas la
circulation on voit aussi que des
vérités d'hier n'en sont pas forcément
aujourd'hui je pense notamment au fait
qu'on nous a dit par exemple que le
virus circule est assez peu dans les
écoles on voit aujourd'hui le situation
un peu chaotique que vive l'entendre
l'ensemble de nos établissements
scolaires et donc il nous semble utile
pour aller plus loin dans le débat que
le gouvernement s'engage à faire en
quelque sorte un bilan un retour
d'expérience des mesures d'ores et déjà
mises en oeuvre pour que chacun et
notamment nos concitoyens puissent juger
de leurs bénéfices ou non en termes de
santé publique puisque c'est évidemment
ça et seulement cela qui doit nous
guider aujourd'hui je crois que ce
serait utile notamment dans le niveau de
tension que ce débat a pu parfois
connaître et que ce serait de bonne
augure que le gouvernement accepte de
donner ce signe d'un d'une gestion un
peu plus collective de cette crise je
vous remercie monsieur le rapporteur
- le rapporteur c'est monsieur le
rapporteur oui monsieur le président
écoute et il y à déjà dans la loi
l'obligation de remettre
rapport mensuel est là
l'amendement nous nous propose que le
gouvernement ne puisse pas proposer de
modification de la loi sans le faire sur
la base d'un rapport il ya déjà dans la
constitution l'obligation de l'étude
d'impact mais on voit à quel point elle
est vidée de sa substance quand on
consulte l'étude d'impact qui a été
préparé pour le présent projet de loi
alors je comprends la motivation
de nos collègues du groupe communiste
mais en même temps si vous le permettez
je considère que nous ne pouvons pas
multiplier les rapports alors qu'il y en
a déjà beaucoup et chaque semaine
d'ailleurs le président du sénat reçoit
un descriptif de l'évolution de la
situation sanitaire il me semble qu'on
ne peut pas ici subordonner la
présentation d'un projet de loi ce qui
est une prérogative gouvernementale
après l'adoption de ce texte en conseil
des ministres à la remise d'un rapport
au parlement ça ça n'est pas dans
l'ordre de nos institutions la vie et
donc défavorable merci monsieur le
rapporteur socialiste même avis
défavorable
je mets aux voix cet amendement 154 avec
deux avis défavorables qui et pour
qui et contre
qui s'abstient il n'est pas adopté deux
amendements en discussion commune 33
monsieur daumier
merci monsieur prétend donc cet
amendement vise à ce que dès le début de
l'examen de ce texte
on le travaille dans un cadre principe
yale qui est celui de l'obligation
universel de vaccination je crois qu'il
ya un large accord pour dire que la
vaccination est un devoir c'est un
devoir
envers les soignants et notre système
hospitalier car il est parfaitement
établi que la vaccination est
heureusement protège particulièrement
efficacement des formes graves celle qui
surchargent nos hôpitaux et c'est un
devoir d envers les autres car si nous
voulons atteindre une protection
collective de notre société face aux
impacts de l'épidémie et la transformer
en une circulation du virus qui pourra
se poursuit mais à bas bruit et sans
impacter nos libertés sans nous
contraindre il faut que nous sommes
vaccinés
passer du devoir à l'obligation est en
l'espèce pour nous une évidence du fait
justement de ces impacts collectif et
donc par ailleurs nous devons france est
un langage de vérité un langage de
rassemblement et appliquer le même
principe à tout le monde et l'énoncé
clairement nous paraît en est la
meilleure preuve on est loin là des
postures politiques et des manipulations
on est dans l'affirmation claire et
simple de ce que les législateurs veut
et par ailleurs et dans ce temps très
court je terminerai par ce point là pour
poursuivre mon exposé de tout à l'heure
c'est que c'est un principe le durable
qui nous permet de nous inscrire dans la
durée qu'il faut prévoir de gestion de
la circulation de ce virus car cette
durabilité de principe après doit
s'accompagner d'une adaptation des
moyens de contrôle qui sont nécessaires
je remercie merci chers collègues le 149
mcqueen
merci monsieur le président
effectivement nous l'avons vu et nous
avons ce débat depuis tout à l'heure la
vaccination est vraiment qu'une une arme
importante pour combattre ce virus là où
nous sommes plus interrogatifs c'est sur
la question de l'obligation vaccinale
pour les moins de 12 ans parce que
effectivement et bien nous n'avons pas
le recul suffisant pour en tirer toutes
les conséquences et avoir un bilan exact
est un peu exhaustif de ce que
représente la vaccination pour les moins
de 2 de 12 ans aujourd'hui d'ailleurs le
monde médical n'est pas unanime il ya il
ya des points de vue qui sont qui sont
divers par rapport à cette vaccination
par exemple le professeur jean françois
delfraissy que nous avons auditionné
nous a fait part du fait que les
pédiatres était plutôt mitigé sur 7 sur
cette indication
il nous semble que effectivement il
serait important de pouvoir vacciner
les enfants qui présentent une des
problèmes de comorbidité et donc à ce
moment là c'est important pour ces
enfants d'être vaccinés mais que pour
les autres ça pourrait effectivement
seulement reposer sur le volontariat
c'est à dire en fait quand on parle de
volontariat bien évidemment il s'agit
d'une prise de décision par les parents
comme il est il et il est prévu dans la
loi d'autre part au moment où on a ce
débat et je veux être extrêmement
prudentes et le dire avec beaucoup
d'humilité parce que les choses évoluent
mais dans l'état actuel des
connaissances il nous semble que healy a
très peu de formes sévères chez les
heureusement chez les enfants de moins
de 12 ans donc que ça peut ne pas
entraîner une pression supplémentaire
sur les hôpitaux ce qui peut être un
argument aussi pour défendre cette
vaccination donc voilà notre
interrogation et voilà le sens de notre
amendement je vous remercie monsieur le
président merci chers collègues sur ces
deux amendements madama rapporteur
merci monsieur le président je connais
je reconnais la position constante du
groupe socialiste pour l'obligation
vaccinale
ça au moins le mérite de la clarté nous
avons eu l'occasion d'en débattre en
particulier monsieur le président
caennais rne lorsque nous avons examiné
votre ppl au mois d'octobre dernier
et je suis pas loin de 2 2 de me
rapprocher de vos positions en disant
que effectivement
effectivement nous reconnaissant avec
vous l'intérêt majeur de la vaccination
par contre mettre en place une
obligation vaccinale qui dit obligation
dit contrôle et sanction c'est par
conséquent très difficile à mettre en
oeuvre et pour cette raison la
commission a émis un avis défavorable
concernant la mort en héros 149 de
madame à ça si je rappelle
qu'actuellement il n'y a pas
d'obligation vaccinale pour les enfants
lobby l'obligation vaccinale n'est
uniquement que pour les personnels
soignants donc les enfants sont exclus
de cette obligation vaccinale
avis défavorable avec des pharmaciens
des ministres
nous nous rejoignons sur l'objectif mais
pas forcément sur les moyens et c'est
pas il n'ya pas d'un conflit idéologique
est d'ailleurs y'a pas un un gap
monumental infranchissable entre les
positions de chacun nous considérons que
la question de l'obligation vaccinale
qui peut se poser dans débat public et
qui est totalement légitime
l emporte des conséquences dans sa mise
en oeuvre qui ne nous semble pas
aujourd'hui
rassembler toutes les conditions
préalables qu'est ce que ça veut dire
l'obligation vaccinale quand c'est pour
les tout petits on sait pour les
nourrissons vous ne pouvez pas aller en
crèche pouvait pas les en halte-garderie
pouvait pas avoir d'assistantes
maternelles pouvait pas rentrer à
l'école ciblé par exxon et s'agissant
des soignants on le sait aussi vous ne
pouvez pas rentrer dans un établissement
de santé pour y exercer si vous n'avez
pas présenter un certificat de
vaccination on le connaît aussi pour des
démarches d'ordre individuel comme si
vous allez en guyane vous devez être
vaccinés contre la fièvre jaune et
présenter votre certificat pour pouvoir
y aller mais pardonnez moi vous me dites
oui et vous avez raison mais c'est
triste mais justement le fait d'aller en
guyane nécessite que je présente impasse
de vaccination sinon je ne peux pas y
aller c'est le choix tous avoir tenu un
système de passes pour entrer dans les
lieux dans des endroits en tenant compte
en plus des facteurs de risque de
transmission du virus parce qu'on y est
ni évidemment un intérêt c'est pas le
supplément d'âme c'est l'intérêt médical
que de réduire les risques de
contamination dans les endroits que dans
les établissements recevant du public
concerné
obligation vaccinale ça veut dire que
vous allez mettre un système parce que
tic idi obligations du contrôle et qui
dit contrôler 10 ans pions est ce que ce
sont des contrôles dans la rue on
demande aux gens de montrer
certificat attestant qu'ils sont
vaccinées sans quoi on leur met des
amendes est ce que on a un fichier
national du patient ou le voteriez même
des messieurs les sénateurs deux
personnes non vaccinées qui serait
visité par des parts des gens avec doté
du pouvoir de police est ce que c'est
une amende de 52 sort de 200 euros
qu'est ce qu'on fait dans qu'est ce
qu'on fait qu'est ce qu'on fait en
matière qu'est ce qu'on fait en matière
qu'est ce confort matière de sanctions
financières pour des familles qui sont
précaires qui est aussi parmi les gens
ne sont pas vaccinés des gens qui sont
précarisées qui sont précarisées donc ça
pose des difficultés aussi d'un point de
vue financier bref nous avons considéré
et avec l'esprit ouvert sur cette
question vous l'aurez compris c'est pas
c'est pas un nom d'andy cus avons
considéré que l'outil du pass vaccinale
était un outil qui emportait de
conséquences favorables dans la
direction que nous souhaitons suivre et
qui est la même que la vôtre c'est à
dire arriver vers 100% vaccination
c'est non seulement est bien une
incitation très forte à être vacciné
sans courbe pu aller dans les bars les
restaurants etc et en même temps un
outil de réduction des riches puisque
oui quand on est totalement vacciner à
jour avec son pass vaccinale les études
nous montrent le même avec au micro et
une réduction des contaminations qui
s'opère donc c'est le dispositif que
nous avons choisie nous ne disons pas
nous ne disons pas encore une fois que
se poser d'autres questions se serait-il
légitime ou inappropriés simplement que
le principe de réalité en l'occurrence
nous semble clairement penché du côté du
nasdaq sinal un avis défavorable malama
sénatrice s'agissant de la vaccination
obligatoire des enfants elle n'est pas
sur la table et donc rappelé dans la loi
quelque chose qui n'y figurent pas enfin
rappelé de ne pas l'inscrire dans la loi
quelque chose qui ne figurent pas ne
nous semble pas nécessaire en tout cas
pas dans ce texte
merci monsieur le ministre monsieur
savary pour explication de vote
oui merci monsieur le ministre vous
trouvez pas de
d'arguments pour pouvoir contrôler une
vaccination obligatoire
éventuelles
le contrôle c'est le pasok sinal quoi
vous mettez donc vous mettez le contrôle
sans l'obligation donc quelque chose ya
pa plus de la fois plus de poids plus
d'incohérence
qu'ailleurs dans ce type de raisonnement
non moi je voulais rappeler que c'est
quelque chose qui mérite discussion et
rappeler surtout contrairement à ce qui
a été dit que la vaccination a fait la
preuve très largement que ça diminuer
les complications ça je crois que tout
le monde on est d'accord mais aussi la
preuve que ça limite la transmission
quand même du virus c'est la raison pour
laquelle il est important de prendre un
certain nombre de deals de deux
dispositions sa limite également certes
de façon moindre mais ça limite la
transmission du virus c'est tout à fait
important c'est pour ça que vous
pratiquez la politique du duo en même
temps fait le contrôle sur dire
l'obligation c'est une politique qui
aurait été sûrement plus clair si les
décision qui a été prise n'est pas été
pas fait de bric et de broc mais était
très clair vis-à-vis des français hélas
les difficultés qu'on rencontre c'est
elles ne sont pas suffisamment clair par
contre en ce qui concerne l'âge je crois
que les décisions qui doivent être
prises sont bien sûr en fonction de
l'âge et vous les avez prises
vaccination
au troisième vaccination pour les
enfants au dessus de 12 ans mais je
pense qu'il faudrait modifier légèrement
ça et faire au dessus de 12 ans ou
l'entrée en collège ça permettrait
d'avoir moins deux diffusions quand même
dans les collèges puisqu'il ya quelques
enfants qui n'ont pas 12 ans et qui se
retrouvent en collèges dans les lycées
ils sont tous et vaccination conseillers
ils sont largement vacciner et je pense
que on pourrait envisager de réduire aux
collégiens là
à la vaccination
pour les enfants et non pas liées à
l'âge spécifique de 12 ans m chers
collègues monsieur le comte oh
oui merci monsieur le président monsieur
le ministre mes chers collègues je suis
assez étonné de l'argumentation de ce
ministre parce que
c'est quand même la vaccination notre
collègue vient de le rappeler a des
effets positifs sur le long terme c'est
une solution de long terme contre les
contre les formes graves contre la
contamination même si c'est pas parfait
et aussi par conséquent contre
l'embolisation de notre système de santé
donc c'est un une solution de long terme
face à cette situation et donc par
rapport à ça monsieur le ministre vous
nous dites
il ya d'autres manières d'y arriver que
de poser le principe
mais à partir du moment où nous au sein
du groupe socialiste nous considérons
que c'est un acte citoyen
de se faire vacciner il est logique de
poser l'obligation vaccinale comment
voulez vous
posez que c'est une obligation citoyenne
si vous ne posez pas l'obligation
vaccinale la question après du contrôle
c'est une autre chose
mais la question de l'acte citoyen et de
dire que compte tenu de la situation sur
le long terme la seule méthode c'est de
poser ce principe de l'obligation
vaccinale la question du contrôle elle
vient après monsieur le ministre les
français sont des citoyens se sont pas
des hamsters de laboratoire qu'on doit
simplement stimuler pour arriver à une
certaine objectif vous ne parlez pas aux
français en leur disant si vous voulez
aller en discothèque ou s'ils voulaient
au restaurant à ce point là il faut
avoir un qr code non vous leur dites
d'abord vous leur dites d'abord
si vous voulez être être citoyen dans la
situation actuelle
c'est remplir un certain nombre de
conditions dont celle ci c'est la raison
pour laquelle nous posons ce principe de
l'obligation vaccinale qui est une
solution de long terme est aussi la
seule manière de dire que cindy
d'obligations est un acte citoyen que de
le faire et de le faire jusqu'au bout
voilà c'est c'est de cette manière là
par la conviction qu'on y arrivera le
contrôle du plus venir après
mais ce n'est pas parce qu on convainc
pas qu'on doit contrôler merci cher
collègue madame la présidente rossignol
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre ça fait deux fois que je vous
entends deux jours
extrapolé sur un éventuel triptyque
vaccins obligatoires
contrôle sanction comme si vous ministre
de la santé vous ignoriez ce que je ne
crois pas un instant que votre
prédécesseur a rendu obligatoire 11
vaccins pour les enfants inscrits dans
le code de la santé publique qu'il n'y a
qu'elle a supprimé toute sanction il n'y
a pas de sanctions en revanche il y à
une
contrainte c'est que ces vaccins sont
indispensables pour s'inscrire à la
crèche ou à l'école donc il est possible
d'avoir des vaccins obligatoires sans
sanction et qui sont la clé qui vous
permette d'aller dans un certain nombre
de lieux socialiser c'est ce que nous
proposons c'est ce que nous proposons
aujourd'hui ce n'est pas une sanction
pénale c'est pas une sanction civile
c'est une c'est une restriction de la
fréquentation de certains nombres de
d'un an de lieux sociaux donc voilà nous
sommes pour l'obligation vaccinale parce
que selon les études de santé publique
france la vaccination est plus forte
chez les personnes habitent en ville que
chez ceux habitant en milieu rural chez
les pères casse favoriser ou supérieur
et le taux de vaccination est plus
faible chez les bénéficiaires de l'ass
et deux aces l'excès et musset la
vaccine la non vaccination n'est pas
qu'une affaire d'exciter complotistes
elle est aussi une affaire de classe de
classe sociale et de classes socio
culturel et vous y apportez et de prix
en république donne tous les sous titres
une réponse de classe en dix ans ceux
qui ne seront pas vaccinés n'iront pas
au restaurant n'iront pas au café
n'iront pas au cinéma ne prenons pas le
tgv c'est très bête mais tout ce dont je
viens de parler ils vont déjà pause
restaurant parce qu'un appât dans leur
quartier a pas de cinéma ils prennent
pas le tgv donc le choix que vous faites
de refuser la vaccination obligatoire
c'est celui de refuser de protéger les
plus vulnérables de notre société en les
amenant à la vaccination pour qu'ils ne
développent pas les formes graves de la
maladie 10 c'est une raison suffisante
pour la vaccination obligatoire si cher
collègue monsieur cozic m
monsieur cozic
ce président merci monsieur le ministre
si vous me permettez je vais paraphé
winston churchill qui disait que la
grande leçon de la vie c'est que parfois
ce sont les fous qui ont raison et en
octobre dernier c'est bien de fou que
l'on nous qualifier lorsque nous
proposions la vaccination obligatoire
pour tous
force est de constater qu'aujourd'hui
les événements nous donnent raison
nous avions raison bien avant vous
monsieur le ministre lorsque vous
donniez un avis défavorable à notre
proposition de loi ce projet de loi
aujourd'hui arrive bien trop tard
si vous nous aviez écouté à l'automne
dernier nous n'en serions pas là la
cacophonie que ce texte à propos a
provoqué à l'assemblée nationale est
symptomatique du désordre ambiant
de plus alors que désormais le président
candidat non-déclaré vient de prendre la
présidence tournante de l'europe il peut
s'appuyer sur ce qui se fait chez nos
voisins européens
en effet pour certains la vaccination
obligatoire est un chemin sur lequel ils
se sont engagés à l'instar de l'autriche
ou d'italie bon nombre de pays mettre en
oeuvre cette vaccination obligatoire
le groupe socialiste avait raison bien
avant tout le monde je n'oublie pas que
nous étions le seul groupe politique et
ça a été rappelé dans l'hémicycle
apporter une mesure aussi responsable
que nécessaire
monsieur le ministre si le président
n'avait pas fait preuve de toute la
verticalité qui lui sied depuis le début
du mandat il aurait pu voir que notre
proposition n'avait pour but que de
protéger nos concitoyens nous voilà donc
aujourd'hui réduit à débattre d'un texte
qui semble n'être que l'antichambre
d'une obligation vaccinale déguisés afin
d'apaiser le pays et d'éviter des
bavardages intempestifs
il est grand le temps monsieur le
ministre que nous passions à
l'obligation vaccinale vous aviez raté
le coche il ya trois mois par cet
amendement
le groupe socialiste vous donne
l'occasion de corriger cette erreur
merci cher collègue madame cohen
oui moi je suis donc sur un autre un
autre amendement puisque c'était sur la
vaccination pour les moins de 12 ans
j'ai bien entendu et la rapporteure et
monsieur le ministre qui disent que
finalement ça n'est pas dans la loi donc
ya pas de raison de le réaffirmer
simplement c'est un débat que nous
souhaitions ouvrir au niveau de mon
groupe parce que effectivement agnès
buzyn ministre de la santé il ya
quelques temps a rendu obligatoire 11
vaccins pour les enfants et donc c'est
quelque chose qui peut arriver
à partir de là nous voulions attirer
votre attention monsieur le ministre
mais j'ai eu le sentiment que ça n'était
pas dans l'est dans les cartons
immédiatement cette vaccination
obligatoire pour les moins de 12 ans
contrôlé contre lacko vide donc nous
allons retirer notre amendement mais le
débat reste ouvert et en tout cas nous
au niveau de notre groupe on est enfin
très attachés au fait de faire confiance
aux pédiatres et de permettre que la
vaccination pour les enfants se passe le
mieux possible même si on sait que les
pédiatres devienne une spécialité de
plus en plus rare sur les territoires
merci chers collègues le président kader
merci monsieur plusieurs monsieur
ministre mesdames et messieurs mes chers
collègues je crois qu'on peut dire que
notre pays va mal quand on regarde de
près le sondage de l'ifop paru il ya
deux ou trois jours dans le parisien on
voit que plus de la moitié de nos
concitoyens sont prêts à supprimer le
financement des hospitalisations pour
celles et ceux qui ne sont pas vaccinés
c'est une atteinte extraordinaire à
notre modèle social si le pays va mal
monsieur le ministre c'est parce que
nous nous considérons que finalement
depuis de nombreux mois eh bien vous
mener une politique endogène
incompréhensible on a plus de six mois
que nous réclamons l'obligation
vaccinale universel d'amendement en
amendement de ppl en pp l2 comité de
liaison parlementaire en comité de
liaison parlementaire vous m'avez
toujours vous même monsieur castaic nous
avait toujours dit non avec parfois je
ne cache pas un brin d'ironie tout à
fait regrettable vous y est opposé et
vous vous étonnez maintenant qu'il reste
des non vaccinés et vous leur faites
portait d'ailleurs la responsabilité des
problèmes de l'hôpital prison de la
république nous explique qu'il a préféré
l'incitation à l'obligation j'ignorais
que pour convaincre il fallait emmerder
les récalcitrants j'ignorais que pour
convaincre qu'il fallait décider seul
dans le huis clos d'un conseil de
défense qu'il fallait désigner des boucs
émissaires et nourrir la division dans
une logique cynique de calcul électoral
monsieur le ministre je pense qu' il
vaut mieux le consentement par la
pédagogie à l'autorité kishwar qui
serait brutale autant pour moi mais
peut-être que je me suis égaré je suis
d'un du vieux monde nous ne sommes pas
opposés au pass vaccinale encadré nous
sommes pas opposés aux pas d'accident
l'encadré je dis simplement que nous
préférons l'obligation vaccinale c'est à
dire de faire reposer sur l'état et non
sur les non-vaccinés une obligation de
faire monsieur le ministre en conclusion
je vous dirais que si des français
aujourd'hui ne sont pas encore
convaincus ce n'est pas à eux qu'il faut
s'en prendre mais à ceux qui n'ont pas
été capables d'être convaincant merci
chers collègues
c'est encore une demande d'explications
de vote juste avant je forme les
collègues que il ya une demande de
scrutin public sur cet amendement donc
si vous pouvez vous préparer monsieur
kerrouche
si monsieur le président chez mini ce
texte et on en conviendra tout ce n'est
pas un texte d'urgence plus exactement
il ne répond plus à l'urgence ou à la
situation qui se déroule sous nos yeux
il est désormais trop tard en la matière
et donc c'est un texte qui est censé
être là pour prévoir et justement
prévoir c'est ce que nous vous proposons
depuis six mois
donc l'équation est simple monsieur min
soit la vaccination est obligatoire et
il y à des interdictions et des
sanctions qui peuvent être posées
ça existe pour d'autres vaccins soit il
n'y a pas d'obligation et dans ce cas il
est difficile d'interdire et de
sanctionner soit le gouvernement croit à
la vaccination obligatoire soit ils n'y
croient pas et dire qu'il s'agit d'une
vaccination déguisé ne suffit pas et
n'est pas suffisant
il peut pas y avoir simplement l'outil
c'est à dire le pass vaccinale sans
l'obligation vaccinale qui est la
finalité et c'est ce que nous vous
demandons dans cette dans cet amendement
est peut-être qu'il est enfin temps de
voter celui ci pour rattraper le temps
que nous avons perdu jusque là merci
chers collègues alors j'ai eu trois
demandes supplémentaires et on
s'arrêtera là
monsieur janvier
merci merci monsieur le président
moi je voudrais dire j'ai écouté avec
beaucoup d'attention
l'intervention d'olivier ferrand du
ministre quand votre prédécesseur
monsieur le ministre a sollicité notre
appui pour étendre la vaccination
obligatoire ce qui était opposé à sa
disposition et je vous invite à relire
les débats de l'époque ont tenu à peu
près les arguments que vous venez de
tenir
les opposants ont tenu à peu près les
arguments que vous avez tenu et nous
nous avons soutenu la ministre de la
santé et son projet en responsabilité
parce que nous sommes attachés à une
politique sanitaire au service des
français et pas à prendre des postures
pardon et le résultat c'est que trois
ans après
le taux de vaccination des enfants qui
stagnait autour de 85 % ce qui nous
empêchait d'éradiquer certaines maladies
les infectiologues nous l'ont confirmée
est monté au dessus de 90 % et on est en
voie d'éradication de ces maladies et
laurence rossignol à rappeler que le
contrôle et la sanction sont de vraies
questions mais qu'elle vienne avec le
principe avec le pass vaccinale sans
obligation vous inventez le contrôle
sans le principe vous inventez l'outil
sans la valeur qui légitiment l'outil et
c'est choquant politique et c'est
choquant face aux français donc nous
vous appelons simplement vous êtes
proche effectivement de tenir un
discours de vérité mais vous êtes
contraint par la voie qui a été choisie
depuis des mois et des mois et moi
j'appelle chacun se prononcer en
conscience et j'invite la majorité
sénatoriale
a a comme notre collègue savary j'ai cru
comprendre
à défendre cette valeur cette valeur
simple de l'obligation vaccinale et
après nous débattrons dans cet hémicycle
ne vous inquiétez pas monsieur le
ministre du contrôle et de la sanction
si nécessaire et nous en débattrons de
façon complètement apaisées
transparentes devant les français merci
monsieur mari
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le président je ministre
on peut s'interroger de savoir si le
choix du gouvernement ne serait pas de
laisser courir le variant au micron en
vue d'obtenir une forme d'immunité
collective en tout état de cause le pass
vaccinale que vous nous proposez ne va
rien apporter de nouveau aux 80 % de nos
concitoyens qui ont leur schéma vaccinal
il n'y a pas d'urgence pour eux
malheureusement un certain nombre
d'entre eux contracte tout de même ce
variant et ne font que des formes
légères mais vous avez choisi de
contraindre les 20% restants et je ne
reprends pas les propos du président de
la république pour les qualifier nous
nous choisissons de convaincre en posant
le principe de l'obligation vaccinale
nous posons un principe de
responsabilité
celui de se protéger celui de protéger
les autres et celui de protéger nos
libertés nous choisissons d'aller vers
ces publics éloignés pour des raisons
sociales et socioculturels et bien
évidemment nous mettons en oeuvre à
l'égard des récalcitrants pour raisons
idéologiques les moyens nécessaire de
les contraindre vous mettez le contrôle
avant le principe est donc se passe
vaccinale aujourd'hui est un outil qui
ne va rien apporter de nouveau
merci maman de la gontrie non
donc
oui monsieur le ministre
je voudrais pas qu'on se quitte sur une
sur un malentendu madame la sénatrice
rossignol
et monsieur le sénateur john y est je
sais très bien ce que j'ai voté quand
j'étais parlementaire sur l'obligation
vaccinale
l'obligation vaccinale et aux vaccins
pour les pour les enfants que j'ai voté
qu'est ce qu'elle dit elle dit que si
vous n'êtes pas vacciné vous ne rentrez
pas à l'école ça s'appelle comment en
termes actuels ça s'appelle un pass
vaccinale pour entrer à l'école au lieu
d'à peine 1 passe donc donc vous vous
comparez vous dites nous avons eu le
courage de voter sable c'est très bien
moi aussi et ça s'appelle un pass
vaccinale ça s'appelle un pass vaccinale
et j'ai pour ça que j'ai pris aussi
l'exemple de la fièvre jaune j'ai un
pass vaccinale pour aller orgueil annecy
j'ai pas mon pass vaccinale pour la
fièvre jaune je n'y vais pas donc toutes
les obligations vaccinales qui existe
dans notre pays repose sur un dispositif
qui passe vous avez voté l'obligation
vaccinale pour les soignants et je vous
en remercie mais qu'est ce qu'a dit
l'obligation excellent pour les
soignants je ne rentre pas à l'hôpital
si je ne suis pas vacciné s'appelle
impasse vaccinale pour entrer à
l'hôpital bon donc temps des mets
alors si je comprends et je pense que je
pense je pense que j'ai compris ce que
vous voulez dire donc nous ne donnons
pas le même sens au mot vous êtes en
train de dire nous on veut bien voté
l'obligation vaccinale en disant que ça
correspond à une obligation par contre
on veut pas voter de passes vaccinale
sans dire ça correspond à une obligation
al'inverse ce qu'alain vers ce que je
vous dis c'est voter voter le principe
d'une oblique alors d'accord voté le
principe d'une obligation universelle de
vaccination dans la loi sans dispositif
de contrôle et sans dispositif de
sanctions le cas échéant ça n'existe pas
obligation sans contrôle n'est que ruine
de la loi mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs on est obligé on est obligé de
mettre des dispositifs et on dit la
nature des choses imaginez fallait que
je vous propose je vous propose qu'on en
avance sur ce sujet mais si je vous
avais dit il ya quelques mois
l'obligation vaccinale pour les
soignants voter là puis on verra plus
tard comment est ce qu'on a fait
respecter m'auriez dit ça va pas aurait
dit on veut savoir ce qu on vote on veut
savoir les tenants et aboutissants d'une
loi et quand on crée une obligation dans
la loi on met toujours des sanctions et
des contrôles ça n'existe pas une
obligation brutes ça n'a pas de valeur
normative à la belle valeur juridique je
comprends que ce soit plus élégant
politiquement de dire nous sommes pour
l'obligation sans dire comment le faire
je vous dis juste il voulait qu'on
débatte projet contre projet allez plus
invente que cela et dites nous ce que
vous mettez sur la table en matière de
dispositifs de contrôle et le cas
échéant de sanctions encore une fois je
ne connais pas d'obligation dans la loi
qui n'avaient pas de pair avec
dispositif de contrôle et de sanction
jeu donc je fais pas une c'est pas un
non idéologique c'est un appel à aller
un peu plus loin dans la description du
dispositif tel que vous le réfléchissez
chinese man à mme de la gontrie
finalement
merci monsieur le président oui j'avais
retiré mon inscription mais en entendant
le ministre je me permet tout de même de
prendre la parole parce que soit soit le
ministre n'a pas totalement
n'a pas totalement entendu pourtant nous
avons été nombreux à nous exprimer et
nous n'avons sans doute pas été assez
clair et donc je vais résumer très
précisément la position de mon groupe
nous proposons l'obligation vaccinale
bien nous proposons dans l'amendement
d'ailleurs une sanction une amende 135
euros
mais nous avons indiqué aussi monsieur
le ministre et chacun a dit bernard
jomier patrick anr tout le monde que
nous étions d'accord avec le pass
vaccinale pour le vérifier donc tout ce
que vous venez de dire où vous indiquer
que nous proposons une obligation sans
contrôle est totalement au sujet ce
n'est absolument pas ce n'est abstenait
absolument pas ce que nous proposons
donc je précise bien les choses d'autant
que nous allons voter parce que tu un
public dans quelques instants
obligation vaccinale principes
transparence égalité pour tous et non
pas simplement dire que on est un peu
grossi à l'égard des non vaccinés j'ose
même pas prononcer le mot don principes
et
vérification contrôle etc avec le pass
vaccinale vous avez là l'ensemble du
dispositif qui semble vous convenir je
vous ai entendu tout à l'heure je vous
écoute avec beaucoup d'attention dire ce
n'est pas un nom mordicus donc j'entends
quand même qu'il y a un intérêt pour nos
propositions j'ai entendu notre collègue
rapporteur de la commission des affaires
sociales évoquée elle même voilà je ne
veux pas du coup excédé son propos un a
priori intéressés on va dire positif je
ne sais pas comment qualifier bref donc
voilà donc monsieur le ministre ne fait
pas de contresens ne le fait pas ni par
habileté à dire les choses gentiment ni
par incompréhension j'espère que
désormais c'est bien clair dans votre
esprit ce que vous allez refusez donc
c'est une obligation vaccinale
nonobstant l'instauration d'un contrôle
avec le pass vaccinale tels que nous
l'accepterions merci cher collègue
monsieur chassang
le président monsieur le ministre mes
chers collègues donc si vous voulez il y
a quelques mois lors de
la position de nulle part du parti
socialiste concernant l'obligation ou
mia porte donc je me suis abstenu mais
ce que vient de dire le ministre et 7 ce
projet de loi fait que le pacs vaccinale
va et très près de l'obligation il ya de
la vaccination obligatoire
donc en ce qui me concerne je suis très
favorable bien sûr à la vaccination
puisque elle réduit énormément
l'hospitalisation d'un rang des soins
critiques
ya quelques mois effectivement je me
suis abstenu parce que on pense et nous
pensions que on était sur la bonne voie
et que c'était pas la peine de faire une
action vaccination obligatoire on
pensait que on allait pouvoir avec le
pass sanitaire s'en sortir
actuellement le gouvernement
fait le pacs vaccinale qui est très près
de l'os de maintenant de la vaccination
obligatoire donc une partie de mon
groupe s'abstiendra et certains voteront
contre
merci chers collègues donc j'ai été
saisi d'une demande de scrutin public
par le groupe socialiste sur
l'amendement 33 je vous rappelle que
l'avis de la commission est défavorable
l'avis du gouvernement est défavorable
il va être procédé au scrutin dans les
conditions fixées par l'article 56 du
règlement le scrutin est ouvert
public qui est dans l'hémicycle
tout premier de l'examen de ce projet de
loi de vaccination est effectivement de
passes vaccinale pardon et vous voyez
c'est sur le sujet de la vaccination
obligatoire les socialistes qui sont à
la manoeuvre avant même le début de
l'examen des articles du texte pour
proposer à nouveau une vaccination
obligatoire en plus du pass vaccinale
des socialistes au sénat qui avait déjà
déposé un texte en ce sens avait examiné
en séance le 13 octobre dernier à
l'époque et bien les socialistes étaient
un peu les seuls à avoir voté un point
la proposition de loi avec 64 votre pour
262 voix contre c'était donc le 13
octobre dernier on va voir si quelques
mois plus tard les positions ont évolué
au sénat revienne en temps par hamdani
et chassa qui dit qu'effectivement ils
avaient voté contre en octobre mais il
voterait maintenant plutôt pour et on
entendu aussi à tous ces arguments des
socialistes qui ont directement comme ça
puis les adresser au ministre de la
santé en disant que est bien avec ce
pass vaccinale yavin obligation
vaccinale qui était masqué et qu'il
fallait être est bien plus simple plus
est bien clair dans la consigne en
mettant un principe de la vaccination
obligatoire c'est un scrutin public ça
signifie qu'au lieu de voter par main
levée les groupes et bien vont voter
avec des cartes magnétiques dans
l'hémicycle et on voit le résultat du
scrutin tout de suite
problème
ça ne demande à voter
le scrutin est clos
voici les résultats du scrutin 70 sur
l'amendement 33 compte tenu de
l'ensemble des délégations de vote
accordés par les sénateurs au groupe
politique est notifié la présidence
nombre de votants 345 nombre de
suffrages exprimés 335 pour la notion 73
contre 262 le sénat n'a pas adopté
l'amendement 149 a été retiré
d'occupation article 1er avec pas mal de
prises de parole monsieur demi
merci messieurs président l'article
premier que nous nous apprêtons à
examiner a généré des débats houleux à
l'assemblée nationale
parfois sans lien direct d'ailleurs avec
l'objet du texte étudié mais comment
pouvait-il en être autrement dans un
pays qui compte 66 millions
d'infectiologie
pardon pour cette ironie qui contraste
avec la gravité de la situation
l'ampleur de la vague épidémique se
confirme jour après jour nos hôpitaux
sont saturés nos soignants sont épuisées
c'est la raison pour laquelle d'ailleurs
je viens de voter l'amendement précédent
et puis il ya l'effet des faits têtus
qui me rappellent mes cours de maths
avec la loi de pareto également appelé
la loi des 20 80 les non-vaccinés
représente 20% de la population mais
peuvent représenter jusqu'à 80 % des
patients en réanimation
ce n'est pas moi qui le dit ce n'est pas
non plus il fredo par est ok mort ya
cent ans
c'est la société française d'anesthésié
et de réanimation
mes chers collègues il ya cent ans
justement au laboratoire pasteur nous
avons découvert le vaccin bilié de
calmette et guérin le fameux bcg qui a
permis de faire chuter la mortalité due
à la tuberculose je rappelle cela cas
dans notre pays cela était dit on ce
vaccin sont actuellement obligatoire
sans ces recherches est censé obligation
de prévention la rougeole la coqueluche
ou encore l'hépatite b ferait encore des
ravages dans notre pays depuis quelques
semaines j'ai le sentiment que nous
sommes dans un débat surréaliste
l'institut pasteur après une étude
portant sur une année estime que la
vaccination réduit la transmission du
virus de 40% un chiffre qui s'approchent
de ceux du conseil scientifique qui a
démontré que la vaccination réduisait le
risque d'hospitalisation de 95 % le
risque d'infection de 60% et le risque
de transmission de 50% s'il ya bien des
moments où l'union nationale pourraient
ou devraient faire sens c'est bien dans
des drames comme celui que nous
traversons celui qui vous parle a fait
un séjour conséquent en réanimation pour
tout à fait autre chose je ne souhaite à
personne de connaître les conséquences
physiques cognitive et psychologique
d'une telle des connexions parce que je
suis effectivement nourrit d'une
douloureuse expérience personnelle parce
que je suis outré de l'attitude de ceux
qui oublient que la liberté des uns
s'arrête
là où commence celle des autres parce
que je considère que rejeter ce texte
insulte à la communauté scientifique
je voterai l'article 20 et l'ensemble de
tête à 6 madame muller brawn
merci merci monsieur le président le
texte que nous examinons s'intitule
projet de loi renforçant les outils de
gestion de la crise sanitaire et
modifiant le code de la santé publique
mais en réalité nous l'entendons il y en
a qu'un seul la vaccination en nous
avons aujourd'hui suffisamment de recul
pour constater que ce seul outil n'est
pas assez efficace alors que même
aujourd'hui 90% de la population est
vaccinée vous conviendrez avec moi
j'espère que les résultats premiers
attendus ne sont pas atteints notamment
en terme de durée et que la troisième
dose ne mettra pas fin à la circulation
du virus
et pourtant c'est exclusivement sur cet
outil qui reposerait demain la santé et
la vie des français jusqu'à l'absurde
puisque les gens vaccinés mais testés
positifs pourront accéder à tous les
lieux de contamination tandis que le non
vaccinés testés négatifs devra s'isoler
précisons que ce que vous appelez
désormais le nom vacciner comprend les
vaccinés qui ont reçu deux doses j'ai
une pensée pour ceux qui ont subi des
effets secondaires graves et que l'on
traite aujourd'hui de non vacciner
puisque c'est devenu une insulte y
compris dans la bouche de notre
président il n'y a pas de citoyens
irresponsables et encore moins de non
citoyens dans cette crise sanitaire en
revanche il y a une stratégie du tout
vaccinal qui ne fonctionne pas car si
c'était la faute des non vaccinés ce
phénomène de forte contamination devrait
être logiquement encore plus virulent
dans les pays voisins moins vacciner que
nous or ce n'est pas du tout le cas
ce qui démontre à la fois les chèques du
pass sanitaires et l'inutilité
d'instaurer un pass vaccinale non
seulement je doute que ce texte de loi
est un réel intérêt sanitaires mais je
crains surtout ses effets délétères sur
notre cohésion nationale et sur la vie
de nos concitoyens dont la santé ne se
résume pas à avoir le co lead ou non j'y
reviendrai dans la discussion des
amendements je vous remercie merci cher
collègue madame benbassa
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre colette toute la complexité de
la gestion de la crise sanitaire tient
dans l'équilibré à atteindre entre les
mesures pour lutter contre le virus et
la préservation de nos libertés cet
équilibre déjà fragilisé par le
précédent projet de loi relative à la
crise sanitaire elles ont pu par ce
texte qui heureusement a été revue à bon
escient bad les commissions pour lutter
contre la copie deal est nécessaire de
disposer d'une stratégie cohérente et
rationnelle afin de proposer des mesures
proportionnées et conciliable avec nos
libertés or il semblerait que cette
stratégie ne s'articule désormais autour
du souhait des manuels macron d'emmerdés
tous les non vaccinés comme il le dit et
cela au détriment de gestion équilibrée
en la fois de la crise est de nos
libertés à l'heure actuelle nous ne
disposons pas d'éléments suffisants pour
établir avec certitude la pertinence de
la mise en place du pass vaccinale le
gouvernement semble lui-même en douter
en se laissant la possibilité de créer
un pass 30 forcé ou un test négatif
devrait présenter en plus de la preuve
d'un schéma vaccinal complet
la défenseure des droits alerte sur
l'absolue nécessité du caractère
proportionné des réflexions or cet
article 1er et l'obligation vaccinale
déguisée qu'il cache ne répond pas à
cette exigence de proportionnalité la
vaccination je suis pour mille fois pour
bien entendu mais pas à n'importe quel
prix nous disposons d'autres outils
qu'ils utilisent est judicieusement
permettrait de préserver mais non
liberté tout en combattant l'épidémie
merci merci cher collègue madame conway
mouret
merci monsieur le président souhaite
attirer monsieur le ministre votre
attention sur les 3 millions de
compatriotes vivant à l'étranger d'abord
il ya eu une introduction ou et yves
impérieux le 30 janvier 2021 cette
mesure jugée disproportionnée par le
conseil d'état en mars entraîné pendant
trois mois et drames humains pour celles
et ceux qui ne répondaient pas un des
vins motifs impérieux et qui n'ont pas
pu rejoindre par exemple un parent
mourant ou des proches sans grande
difficulté puis l'introduction du
passani terre à l'entrée des vacances à
bloquer ceux qui n'étaient pas vaccinés
parce que les vaccins n'étaient pas
disponibles dans leur pays de résidence
où se vacciner par les vaccins pas
reconnu par la france par ailleurs
reconnu par l' oms nouvelle étape le pas
de facs inhalent qui réduit encore les
libertés de mouvements pour celles et
ceux dont le parcours vaccinale n'est
pas reconnu pourtant suivant les pays
les parcours et les avis des
scientifiques diffèrent ainsi au japon
le délai imposé après la deuxième dose
est de huit mois quid de la réactivation
du passani terre et des français qui ne
peuvent avoir la troisième dose avant
d'arriver en france qui n'auront pas
droit aux passes vaccinale j'espère que
vous serez sensible aux amendements que
nous proposons ici nous placerons enfin
dans l'anticipation plutôt que dans la
réaction en tout cas nos amendements le
permettent après nous avons tous compris
que le pass vaccinale n'est pas un outil
de santé publique sinon ils auraient été
introduits pour tous les vaccins
obligatoires c'est un outil pour
contraindre dans la suite des mesures
que je viens de citer et non convaincre
nos compatriotes à se faire vacciner en
stigmatisant cette fois ci minorité
introduisant son exclusion sociale
d'autres solutions sont possibles
il suffit de regarder comment certains
pays sont arrivés à plus de 90% de
vacciner sans clivé sans créer de
tensions dans la société sans instaurer
un contrôle permanent et par tous il
lutte était plus courageux d'assumer le
principe de la vaccination obligatoire
qui a été rappelé par un certain nombre
de mes collègues plutôt que de bricoler
au fil du temps pour arriver à des
mesures de plus en plus punitives et
coercitives qui divise notre société se
croit dans la division dans cet
hémicycle on est un triste reflet chers
collègues me fera ça
merci monsieur le président chez le
ministre si j'interviens aussi à ce
point de l'examen du texte
c'est dans la poursuite de ce que vient
de dire ma collègue hélène conway mouret
pour parce qu'il convient de s'assurer
de la compatibilité de ce pass vaccinale
pour nos compatriotes français de
l'étranger quelle que soit leur pays de
résidence et surtout pour ceux qui
vivent en dehors de l'union européenne
si le vaccin n'est pas homologué il
convient d'une part de s'assurer qu'ils
aient bien la faculté de le mettre à
jour et d'obtenir un délai avec un test
pcr négatif par exemple
sur le ministre nous avons besoin d'un
texte réglementaire qui précise toutes
les conditions dans lesquelles la mise à
jour de leurs passes vaccinale peut être
effectuée pour être valide partout en
france dans les transports les activités
culturelles et les restaurants un autre
sujet important et je l'évoqué hier avec
vous lors de votre audition et la
question du certificat de rétablissement
celui ci n'était pas mentionnée dans la
loi de façon explicite et je remercie
notre rapporteur d'avoir intégré dans le
texte de la commission l'amendement de
notre collègue catherine belrhiti mais
là aussi il faut préciser que les
certificats de rétablissement établi par
des autorités de santé de pays hors de
l'union européenne sont et devrait être
également recevable un exemple pour y
parvenir ne pourrait-on pas aller plus
loin comme le fait la suisse en
demandant la prise en compte d'une
sérologie ce une question que je vous
pose le ciel ministre sur lequel
j'aimerais avoir votre avis voilà
monsieur le président merci c'est un
collègue madame jasmin
président monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues je tiens à vous faire part des
actions des élus de la guadeloupe les
élus de la guadeloupe conseil régional
conseil départemental association des
maires et tous les parlementaires
de l'assemblée nationale et du sénat se
sont régulièrement réunis depuis
plusieurs mois et on souhaitait
améliorer les actions pour que la
population de la guadeloupe soit prise
en compte compte tenu de la situation
sanitaire que nous connaissons
les élus conscients des conséquences les
mobilisations successives
ont également rencontré des
représentants des chambres consulaires
les socioprofessionnels des chefs
d'entreprises déjà une des transporteurs
de passagers de marchandises des
personnes en situation de handicap et
tous les maires ou alors leurs
représentants les élus de la guadeloupe
ont également échangé avec les ministres
de la santé les ministres des outre-mer
le premier ministre le président de la
république et ont pour la plupart
participé aux réunions du comité de
suivi présidé par le préfet
compte tenu de la situation sanitaire
social économique et environnemental et
systémique les élus de la guadeloupe ont
contribué également à l'élaboration d'un
amendement qui a été présenté à
l'assemblée nationale par les députés
bénin mathiasin et vainqueur christophe
et d'autres de leurs collègues
savaient peut-être cet amendement était
repris ici par victorin lurel et moi
même
l'objectif étant d'adapter de façon
différenciée l'application du pass qui
est proposée par le gouvernement je ne
préjuge pas un chien collègues dit choix
qui sera le vôtre je ne sais pas le
choix vous ferez mais j'ai tenu par à
anticiper justement en guadeloupe des
mesures particulières ont été prises
avec la mise en place de structures
d'écouté et une instance de reconversion
pour certains des professionnels qui ne
souhaitent pas se faire vacciner et
sherco l'oeil la situation est difficile
il faut conclure les widgets le terminus
ans j'arrive à la conclusion notre vous
situation aujourd'hui nous les élus nous
avons nous sommes prêts pour les
échanges et nous sommes obligés de
respecter un protocole des méthodes
proposées par les membres du collectif
alors que nous y étions contraints merci
merci j'ai un collègue monsieur jacques
un
merci monsieur le président madame la
rapporteure monsieur le ministre mes
chers collègues je tiens à saluer mon
collègue
bernard jomier de m'avoir fait
progresser sur notre proposition lucides
et courageuses de l'obligation vaccinale
elle m'avait heurté dans un premier
temps et puis après réflexion j'en étais
vraiment convaincu c'est en effet la
responsabilité d'un parlementaire d'un
état de droit démocratique celui de
rousseau et de montesquieu en
l'occurrence dénoncé des droits et des
devoirs de peser les principes
proportionnée en un monde un contrôle
ici le pass vaccinale j'en suis vraiment
convaincu ici avec votre texte ce pass
vaccinale sans obligation vaccinale nous
ne sommes pas dans un état de droit
nous ne sommes pas clair avec ce que
vous appelez vous même une obligation
déguisé la loi ne rend pas obligatoire
la vaccination et pourtant nous empêche
riom certains citoyens de librement
circuler j'étais contre le pass annie
terre sans obligation vaccinale au vu
des débats je pourrais être contre ce
pass vaccinale sans obligation vaccinale
que vous venez de refuser je ne doute
pas mes chers collègues que vous avez lu
l'avis de la défenseur des droits qui
parle d'un rétrécissement des libertés
nous sommes à l'heure d'un basculement
populiste avérée ou la morale
remplacerait le droit nous sommes à
l'heure où notre pays a plus besoin que
tout d'unités d'apaisement je ne peux
m'associer un gouvernement qui tente de
cliver d'emmerdés une partie de nos
concitoyens
vous préférez la morale au droit
monsieur le ministre vers ans je vous
laisse avec cette pensée dérangeante
d'hannah arendt
ceux qui optent pour le moindre mal tant
d' très vite à oublier qu'ils ont choisi
le mâle
collègue monsieur reichardt
c'est le président monsieur le ministre
mes chers collègues je voudrais d'abord
rendre hommage aux deux rapporteurs
ainsi qu'aux deux commissions pour les
évolution largement positive apportée à
ce projet de loi et notamment langues
cadre mans du kazakh sinal pour autant
la question essentielle reste posée
pourquoi faut-il passer du pass
sanitaire au pass vaccinale à titre
personnel je n'en vois pas la logique
alors que la pandémie s'envole en effet
l'obligation n'a pas axial pour accéder
dans certains locaux va-t-elle vraiment
freiner le développement de la pandémie
non pas plus que ne l'a fait le pass
sanitaires ensuite on le sait le post
vaccinale est un pass sanitaires
auxquels on a enlevé deux éléments
l'attestation de test négatif les
certificats de rétablissement pourquoi
on se demande ne plus prendre en compte
un test négatif pour entrer dans les
lieux soumis à passe alors même que
celui-ci garantit bien mieux que le
vaccin l'absence de contamination de son
titulaire en outre il ya là un vrai
paradoxe pourquoi se priver de cet outil
qui constitue que constitue le test
négatif alors même que le gouvernement
s'est fixé une vraie stratégie de tester
toujours plus c'est le terme utilisé
encore hier soir par le premier ministre
au 20 heures de france 2 certes on nous
dit que grâce aux vaccins on diminue le
risque pour les malades de développer
des formes graves de la maladie mais
pense-t-on réellement mes chers
collègues que c'est par un passeport en
vaccinale pour accéder à un restaurant
ou à des lieux de loisir que notamment
les personnes âgées les plus fragiles
vont être amenés à se faire vacciner en
conclusion à mon sens dans la logique
gouvernementale de lutte contre le virus
que je ne partage pas le pass sanitaire
est un outil suffisant il n'est pas
opportun à mon sens d'aller plus loin
vers le pass vaccinale qui est encore
plus contraignants pour les libertés
publiques et c'est la raison pour
laquelle je ne peux pas voter cet
article 1er merci cher collègue monsieur
varela ce madame maria cependant
in his mes chers collègues
comment sommes-nous arrivés là nous
débattons dans l'urgence
l'urgence absolue à l'assemblée
nationale réunie en commission le 29
décembre sur un texte adopté en conseil
des ministres le 27 décembre et le 3
janvier en séance publique urgence
toujours au sénat où nous débattons
aujourd'hui d'un texte adopté en
commission des lois hier dans la foulée
nous débattons donc dans ces conditions
d'un projet de loi qui est loin d'être
anodin aux conséquences lourdes en
matière de libertés publiques mais aussi
sur la santé alors qu'aucune urgence
comme notre collègue bâle a souligné
n'exige les mesures dont nous allons
discuter la vague au micro et là elle
nous dépasse
la virulence de ce nouveau variant est
tel que le gouvernement de toute
évidence hésitent sur la conduite à
tenir en sont témoins les atermoiements
sur le protocole
scolaire or le ministre dans le même
temps monsieur le ministre dans le même
temps vous mobiliser le pays le
parlement l'opinion publique vous créez
de vives tensions en pointant du doigt
les non vaccinés on met en avant le pass
l'accident alors que chacun le reconnaît
cette nouvelle contrainte ne sera pas de
nature à résoudre l'épidémie pourquoi
cette obsession à batailler sur le pass
vaccinale alors que tant de combats plus
efficaces sont amenés pour résoudre
cette crise sanitaire est repoussée
l'épidémie en premier lieu la levée des
brevets qui permettrait à 60 pays qui
sont prêts aujourd'hui à produire les
vaccins sachant que l'om est ce le dise
si 70% des pays de la planète ne sont
pas vaccinés d'autres variantes nous
arriverons oui il faut s'interroger sur
les motivations profondes de cet article
1er de ce texte accompagné par le verbe
outrancier du président de la république
vous détourner l'attention du vrai
problème
l'état de notre système de santé de
l'hôpital à l'assurance maladie de nos
services publics en général à l'image de
l'école des années d'un libéralisme
encensé sans retenue ont désarmé notre
société face aux menaces à cette menace
que ne veut bien sûr nous n'avons pas vu
venir lits d'hôpitaux ferme et numérise
assure que des faucons pur de
l'assurance maladie
cet article 1er même aménagé établi un
dispositif anachronique en décalage avec
la réalité dont le seul objectif est de
dédier ce débat mais aussi nous en
sommes de plus en plus convaincus à
contraindre et à banaliser cette
contrainte cher collègue monsieur
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues moi je
pense qu'il faut beaucoup d'humilité
dans cette crise du côté gouvernemental
comme du côté de l'opposition parce que
qui dit pandémie qui crise à gérer mais
ça n'évite pas monsieur le ministre vous
les joues porte l'apéro et des
cacahuètes est ce que vous voulez
l'apéro les cacahuètes peut-être oui
dites moi je pense si vous souhaitez
monsieur le ministre je peux je peux
vous faire livrer
juste sur une question
juste sur une question vous avez fait un
choix de la gestion de crise seuls
c'est un choix et vous considérez le
parlement comme un
seul ministre je vois bien
vous considérez que le parlement est un
empêcheur de tourner en rond mais moi je
pense que nous pouvons avoir des débats
nous en sommes à doute douze textes en
22 mois et je pense que certains moments
on peut faire le bilan sur un certain
nombre de questions par exemple sur les
lits d'hôpitaux fermée pendant la
pandémie 5000 c'est une question si nous
avions fait le choix au premier au
deuxième ou au troisième texte de mettre
des moyens sur les lits d'hôpitaux nous
affronterions pas de la même façon la
cinquième vague c'est une question la
question la levée des brevets s'il ya un
an nous avions fait un espoir et de sow
est un acte de solidarité internationale
en aidant à construire des usines pour
lever et notamment construire des
vaccins aujourd'hui nous ne saurions pas
dans la situation 50% de la planète n'a
pas accès aux vaccins et pour dernière
chose puisque pour pas être trop long
est resté dans les deux minutes il ya
une question c'est que moi je suis
assez surpris que dans la gestion la
crise sanitaire nous générions jamais le
débat sur l'hôpital public sur les
masques et ex gratuit sur les
purificateurs d'air mais la seule
question c'est au tour des libertés et à
chaque fois nous on nous propose de
restreindre un peu plus nos libertés
pour gagner la sécurité sanitaire mais
on voit que c'est un peu plus compliqué
je redis nous sommes pour la vaccination
est donc
comme ça ne fonctionne pas
malheureusement nous ne voterons pas ce
cet article 1er je vous remercie cher
que la boyer merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre j'associe à la
démarche que je suis en train de faire
ma collègue le docteur françoise
lassarade et puisqu'il s'agit de parler
de ce qu'ont fait les marins pompiers de
marseille et les pompiers de paris en
effet depuis le début de la crise
sanitaire ils ont été pleinement engagés
pour faire face à la pandémie avec
l'appui des élus locaux ils ont cherché
à développer des outils permettant de
gérer d'anticiper l'évolution de la
situation épidémiologique dès l'été 2020
les marins pompiers de marseille ont
commencé à développer une technique
d'analysé des eaux usées cette technique
unique en europe à l'exception des pays
bas permet d'avoir environ une semaine
d'avant sur la circulation active du
virus en effet l'analyse régulière des
eaux usées de marseille apporte des
éléments qui peuvent permettre d'évaluer
la situation de l'épidémie de covile
dans notre ville pour le vice amiral
patrick auger qui est à la tête des
marins pompiers de marseille je le cite
il indique que la précision de ce
dispositif permet de cibler en un temps
record des zones de surveillance et
ainsi d'intensifier les moyens engagés
des acteurs de la crise comme des
évaluations sanitaires ou des dépistages
en fonction des besoins exprimés nous
voyons dans les eaux usées à la fois des
gens asymptomatique et des gens malades
nous voyons par conséquent tout le monde
ce dispositif vient en quelque sorte en
amant et complète les autres données
habituelles de l'évolution du virus
aussi monsieur le ministre au delà du
quoi qu'il en coûte
ainsi je vous demande avec d'autres
collègues sur les autres vend y compris
du groupe socialiste de bien vouloir
lever le gage sur l'amendement que
j'avais déposé qui avait été retoqué au
titre de l'article 40 afin de permettre
cette analyse des eaux usées comme celle
d eau potable j'ajoute que c'est une
recommandation du 17 mars 2021 de la
commission européenne concernant l'
approche commune dans la mise en place
d'une surveillance systématique de la
présence du duc au vide dans les
variantes des eaux usées de l'union
européenne aussi monsieur le ministre
cette poursuite de l'analyse est dans
vos mains puisque nous parlementaires
nous ne pouvons pas engager des dépenses
supplémentaires et il me semblerait tout
à fait utile aujourd'hui
de permettre cette analyse comme celle d
eau potable afin de guider me je vous
remercie merci monsieur laménie
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre chers collègues
concernant cet article 1 qui vise
l'institution d'un pass vaccinale
métropole et territoires ultramarins qui
suscite naturellement beaucoup
de prises de paroles d'amendements aussi
et je crois que c'est aussi le respect
de tous qu'il est important
de mettre en avant sujet extrêmement
sensible puisque malheureusement cette
crise sanitaire mondiale depuis mars
j'irai beaucoup de décès malheureusement
un autour de nous et dans nos
territoires et départements respectifs
et au plan national et mondial
je saluerai bien entendu
nos rapporteur
niveau de la commission des lois la
commission des affaires sociales tout le
travail qui a été fait mais c'est vrai
que les chiffres malheureusement ne sont
pas bons on le voit dans nos
départements respectifs les réunions de
concertation qui sont faits par les
représentants de l'état directeur de la
rs
autorités académiques en direction des
élus sont aussi là pour le prouver
malheureusement
l'article 1
le travail de la commission ont accepté
la transformation du pass sanitaire en
passe vaccinale que dans un cadre
temporaire adapté afin d'assurer la
protection des personnes non vaccinées
l'objectif bien entendu et je m'y
associe c'est aussi sauver des vies
toutes générations confondues il importe
réellement de proches protéger toutes et
tous d'où l'importance du vaccin est la
référence certains collègues l'ont dit
aussi référence
historique avec
pasteur l'institut pasteur et c'est vrai
qu' il importe réellement de vacciner
et trouvez aussi naturellement des
solutions donc c'est pourquoi je
soutiendrai cet article 1er merci cher
collègue mathieu bidon
oui merci monsieur le président je
voudrais tout d'abord dire qu'il ya en
effet comme l'ont dit d'autres collègues
d expression qui ne vont pas bien avec
certaines fonctions il n'en demeure pas
moins vrai que le principal emmerdeur
dans notre pays actuellement c'est bien
le sascoc deux essais variant et que
donc nous devons réfléchir à ce virus
particulièrement nocifs je vais si vous
le voulez bien revenir deux secondes sur
ce qui se passe en région provence alpes
côte d'azur je suis le ministre c'est
président de la fédération hospitalière
de france pour cette région doit vous
dire que les hospitalisations ont
augmenté de 30% dans les dernières
semaines ce qui veut dire que donc cette
augmentation de 30% entraîne pour les
lits occupés par des barres à part ce
code 2 par deco ville plus délit non
occupés par d'autres que dans le cadre
des soins critiques 90% des hospitalisés
en soins critiques sont des non vaccinés
que dans ces conditions évidemment il ya
des actes déprogrammé et médicaux et
chirurgicaux et qu'en provence alpe côte
d'azur ces actes provins mecs
se font également au niveau d'un
pédiatrie puisque d'après professeur
nicolas que vous pourrez rencontrer si
vous désirez 50% des actes chirurgicaux
en pédiatrie ont été déprogrammés à la
suite de cette arrivée massive de ses co
vide cela entraîne évidemment des
programmations monsieur ministre
j'aimerais que vous nous disiez à peu
près combien il ya d'actes des
programmes et sur l'ensemble du
territoire national je croise est au
dessus de près de 2 puis de 2 millions
d'acteurs déprogrammé et médicaux et
chirurgicaux et aussi il ya une chose
qui arrive en paca qui est extrêmement
importante c'est que nous en arrivons à
une saturation à une diminution
considérable des livraisons d'oxygène
médical avec des hôpitaux en particulier
marignane qui se trouvent sans oxygène
médical du fait d'une suite asia
solution utilisation de cet oxygène
médical voilà ce que je voulais vous
dire est donc cet emmerdeur étant
important la vaccination aurait dû être
réfléchie mais réfléchi dès l'arrivée
des vaccins c'est un peu tard maintenant
pour l'obliger et c'est pour ça je me
suis abstenu avec rené paul savary avec
d'autres sur ce sujet enfin dire ni
vraiment je vais voter l'article 1
amende et fort justement par notre
rapporteur et je voudrais vous dire
cette maxime la force de privilégier de
privilégier pardon l'urgence à
l'essentiel on en oublie l'essentiel de
l'urgence merci chers collègues magie
opère
monsieur le président chez le ministre
chers collègues le pain sanitaire n'a
pas montré son efficacité
il suffit de voir les chiffres de
contamination aujourd'hui vous avez été
incapable de justifier de son efficacité
vous enfoncer dans un durcissement des
mesures qui révèle qui relève désormais
de l'absurde quand le premier ministre
annonce que les vaccinés contaminé
pourront prendre le train mais pas les
non-vaccinés négatif dites moi s'il est
nécessaire d'être épidémiologistes faut
comprendre l'absurdité de cette mesure
je ne voterai pas se passe vaccinale non
pas parce que je ne veux pas protégé les
français ou que je suis anti vaccins je
suis médecin et parce que je me refuse à
pratiquer comme vous monsieur le
ministre la politique de la terre brûlée
je suis un enfant du contrat social de
rousseau et je ne veux pas du contrat
du crédit social que vous proposez par
des manoeuvres dilatoires
prison la république à désigner un bouc
émissaire est ce qu'ils ne peuvent
affronter les chèques ont besoin de
boucs émissaires
merci cher collègue monsieur benarroch
merci monsieur le président nos troupes
ne votera pas cet article 1er il
demandera même la suppression par un
amendement de cet article
nous nous opposons l'évolution du passé
ni terre au prince vaccinale pour
l'accès à certains lieux plusieurs
dispositifs de passe en fonction des
lieux du statut vaccinal des personnes
sont remis en place simultanément
provoquant une très grande confusion des
règles et aux risques de mauvaise
compréhension de ces mesures certains
lieux seront accessibles avec le pass
sanitaire classique
comme les centres médico sociaux et les
centres hospitaliers d'autres sont
accessibles avec un pass vaccinale
d'autres avec un pass vaccinale ainsi
qu'un test négatif d'autres avec un pass
vaccinale mais avec des exceptions
quatre motifs impérieux la complexité de
ces mesures loin de permettre d'endiguer
efficacement la pandémie contribuent à
l'épuisement collectif de notre pays
plus généralement d'articles premiers
instants une société de surveillance
exercée par une catégorie de citoyens
sur une autre restreint les droits des
personnes non vaccinées et dans le
sentiment de protection aux personnes
vaccinées qui conduit à l'abandon des
gestes barrières dans les endroits
confinés soumis aux passes pour
intensifier la vaccination il faut
convaincre renforcer la politique de
l'allée vers le taux de vaccination cage
d'être d'importantes disparités
territoriales et la frilosité envers les
vaccins arn messager est toujours très
présente chez des personnes non
vaccinées or ce pays elle ne traite pas
de cette facture et de cette résistance
et désigne les personnes non vaccinées
comme des ennemis de la nation
le v10 n'arrange rien aux mots trop ses
réticences à l'arrivée de novavax
lorsqu'interrogé le 22 12 après sa
validation par les instances sanitaires
européennes il déclare on vaccine en arn
messagers honnêtement c'est le plus
efficace à date d'autres disposent
nous nous opposons d'autres dispositions
de cet article comme le renforcement des
modalités de contrôle du pass le
durcissement des sanctions et la
prolonge et le prolongement de l'état
d'urgence sanitaire à la réunion et en
martinique jusqu'au 31 mars 2022 enfin
nos institutions démocratiques sont
éprouvés par la multiplication des états
d'urgence les risques de pérennisation
des mesures restrictives prises dans le
cadre de ces régimes d'exception sont
avérés et cher collègue monsieur
chassang
mes chers collègues donc en ce qui me
concerne bien sûr je voterai l'article
nous devons à mon sens se mettre en
place un axe vaccinale c'est à dire une
obligation vaccinale un peu déguisé
c'est important pourquoi parce que le
variant delta et le micron flambent mais
flanc par tous mes chers collègues il
faut beaucoup d'humilité comme l'a dit
tout à l'heure notre collègue monsieur
gay car il ya un mois et demi on ne
connaissait pas le micro et sa contagion
gigantesque on ne la connaissais pas non
plus actuellement les médecins
les infirmières les sapeurs-pompiers les
l'hôpital les pharmaciens sont souvent
débordés et grâce à un test ces
vaccinations l'hôpital tient c'est à
dire que en service de soins critiques
et bien malgré la contagion énorme et
bien il y a quand même moins de forme
grave donc le var le var qu au micro
peut-être moins de pathologies graves
mais le nombre va exploser donc on va
avoir avec cela beaucoup de personnes
hospitalisées il faut donc vacciner
vacciner encore quel car les vaccins car
les personnes vaccinées on de forme
moins graves mais sont moins contagieux
le pam le pass vaccinale est donc un
plus et je pense mes chers collègues que
qu'il faut voter cet article un merci
mes chers collègues donc nous entamons
avec quatre amendements identiques le 5
qui madame cohen
oui merci monsieur le président par cet
amendement ne souhaitons supprimer
l'article premier de ce projet de loi
qui remplace le pass sanitaire par un
pass vaccinale comme la développer notre
présidente eliane assassi lors de la
discussion générale nous pensons que
nous franchissons avec ce nouveau pass
vaccinale une nouvelle étape dans
l'atteinte aux libertés fondamentales
je ne prendrai qu'un exemple en
permettant à de nombreuses personnes
restaurateurs responsables
d'établissements de loisirs vigiles et
cetera en leur permettant donc
d'effectuer un contrôle d'identité qui
n'en est pas tout à fait un bien sûr
grâce aux artifices du gouvernement puis
à ceux de la commission des lois mais
qui demeure dans les faits un contrôle
aujourd'hui la contrainte devient la
règle la prolongation et le renforcement
de ce pass est symptomatique de la
situation dans laquelle nous nous
trouvons ou l'exception devient la norme
et où effectivement les lois d'urgence
rentrer dans le quotidien
une fois de plus dans la normalité une
fois de plus le caractère sécuritaire
des mesures prises l'emportent amplement
sur l'aspect sanitaire qui devrait bien
entendu pris mais selon selon nous nous
défendons la vaccination et toutes les
mesures qui peuvent aller dans ce sens
mais il faut inciter et rassurer les
personnes qui sont encore inquiète et
qui refusent de se faire vacciner
ça doit être une priorité dans la
gestion de cette crise sanitaire et je
pense vraiment que on a tort de faire un
groupe de ces non vaccinés il ya des
récalcitrants les antilles vax que rien
ne saurait convaincre mais il ya encore
des gens qui peuvent être convaincus
je pense notamment aux personnes âgées
isolées
il faut aller vers elle il faut discuter
avec elle il faut faire preuve de
pédagogie et je pense aussi y compris à
des gens qui ont eu la première et la
deuxième dose et qui aujourd'hui se pose
des questions donc il faut faire de la
pédagogie et puis ça a été dit par mon
collègue fabien gay il faut avoir des
mesures en termes de santé publique
d'hôpital et notamment en embauchant en
réouvrant les lits en étant de faire une
telle pression sur les personnels de
santé qu'aujourd'hui il quitte
complètement la mort dans l'âme la
région centrale hier l'amendement neuf
malades mais deron
vim
le président ce projet de loi renforçant
les outils de gestion de la crise
sanitaire nous propose de transformer le
pass sanitaire en passe vaccinale sur
quelles bases durcir les mesures et
faire peser sur une minorité de français
de nouvelles restrictions alors que le
pass sanitaires mises en oeuvre depuis
plusieurs mois n'a pas fait la
démonstration de son efficacité pour
lutter contre la comptine contamination
90% de la population française est
désormais vaccinés et les variants 6
successifs ses joues des parce que l'on
veut bien mettre en oeuvre par ailleurs
sans méconnaître les apports de la
vaccination pour les personnes âgées et
fragiles les virologues ne considère
t-il pas comme un non sens la
vaccination de masse le virus a évolué
vers au micron variante très contagieux
est moins virulent qui pourrait
favoriser la protection des français par
l'immunité collective ou naturels
notamment auprès des populations les
plus jeunes et les moins à risque c'est
une stratégie choisie par certains pays
d'autres ont fait le choix d'une pause
avec la quatrième dose faute de réels
bénéfices de la vaccination se passe
vaccinale signe aussi la mort sociale
d'une partie de la population qui n'est
pas délinquante puisque elle respecte la
loi et qu'elle ne transgresse hocklines
interdiction législative
laswell citoyenneté de chaque français
doit elle être tributaire d'une
injection prodiguer tous les trois à
quatre mois jusqu'à maintenant avec le
pass sanitaire cette partie de la
population a su mais assez frais des
tests fréquents qui lui permettait de se
savoir plus ou moins syndicaux vide est
là avec le pass vaccinale on la condamne
à être quasi enfermé de nombreux
scientifiques n'affirme-t-il pas
aujourd'hui que la charge virale d'un
vacciner d'un non vaccinés est identique
aussi seuls des tests gratuits et
systématique pour tous sont en capacité
de protéger toute la population et de
freiner l'évolution du virus et c'est
cette solution qui nous convient de
favoriser il y a donc pas lieu
discriminer les français avec un pass
vaccinale c'est la raison pour laquelle
cet amendement vise à demander la
suppression de l'article
présent projet de loi 6 214 monsieur
benarroch
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre de loi d'urgence sanitaire aux
lois d'urgence sanitaire nous nous
posons la question de savoir quelle est
la justification de celles que vous nous
présentez aujourd'hui y at il un nouvel
état d'urgence sanitaire qui est apparu
qui justifierait une nouvelle loi pour
s'y adapter y at il une volonté
différente de freiner aujourd'hui la
propagation du virus à ces deux
questions nous répondons non et nous
nous demandons encore mettre là pourquoi
cette loi dans l'urgence maintenant au
fait nous nous opposons donc à
l'adoption de ces mesures que nous
paraissent à la fois discriminante et
liberticide nous préfèrerions une autre
politique pour endiguer l'épidémie avec
une aide et un soutien pour le personnel
soignant épuisé une aide soutien
psychologique pour les jeunes un
moratoire sur les fermetures des lits
une généralisation des capteurs de cod
une gratuité de la mise à disposition
des masques en particulier ffp2 une
gratuité des tests une politique de là
les verts et la levée des brevets sur
les vaccins voilà dresser rapidement une
politique nous jugeons autres à un
moment où rien imposerait aujourd'hui de
voter une nouvelle loi d'urgence
sanitaire c'est pour ça que nous devons
d'abord la suppression par cet
amendement de l'article 1 et que nous
voterons contre 7 un triple leurs
collègues 986 monsieur ravier
merci monsieur le président et cher
collègue amendement que je vous propose
vise à supprimer l'article 1 de ce
projet de loi il y à une question de
principe fondamental avant de considérer
les aspects médico sanitaires aux
scientifiques reculer un peu plus sur la
liberté l'égalité la fraternité c'est
confirmé que nous avons mis depuis le
vote du pass à lithaire cet été
le doigt dans un engrenage mortifère de
délitement de notre cohésion nationale
le tout vaccinal est à bien des égards
contestable à court et à moyen terme sur
le plan sanitaire mais des conséquences
du pass vaccinale à long terme sont
surtout délétère sur les plans juridique
et symbolique
ici la finalité de santé publique ne
justifie pas les moyens du tout vaccinal
reculé sur nos principes c'est accepter
un changement de civilisation nos droits
recul nous passons d'une société de
liberté à une société d'autorisation
monsieur le ministre puisque vous nous
accordez pour une fois le respect et
l'honneur de votre présence permettez
moi de m'adresser à vous le fait que
vous instrumentaliser la cause du coc
vide ne veut en aucun cas dire que vous
avez seules les solutions pour régler la
situation solitaire par cet article vous
assumez ne plus vouloir lutter contre la
propagation du virus
quand vous supprimez de la loi mais
contre l'épidémie elle même dieu vous
entende des conséquences juridiques de
cette suppression de ce petit mot sont
lourdes un change la nature des pouvoirs
octroyés au gouvernement en matière de
gestion de la crise sanitaire
par ailleurs l'article premier prévoit
de permettre aux professionnels qui
contrôle les pactes vaccinaux de leurs
clients et café chez les restaurateurs
dijoux un grand contrôle d'identité sans
quoi les sanctions à leur égard pourrait
être alourdi j'ai envie de crier au fou
cette mesure est totalement
disproportionnée quand on sait par
exemple que les policiers municipaux
dans nos communes n'ont même pas la
possibilité de contrôler l'identité
d'une personne suspecte et comme
policier national doit être au pgi ou
sous son autorité et qui doit ensuite
présenter un rapport circonstancié chers
collègues toujours habité par
l'espérance de vous voir changer d'avis
car je suis un éternel optimiste je vous
invite à voter cet amendement de
suppression si j'ai un collègue monsieur
le rapporteur
merci monsieur le président j'ai écouté
évidemment avec beaucoup d'attention
toutes les interventions avant la
discussion des amendements et la
présentation de chacun de ces
amendements il ya beaucoup
d'informations contradictoires
si bien que nos compatriotes sont fondés
à se poser actuellement
des questions auxquelles ils ne trouvent
pas toujours de réponse dans les
décisions qui sont prises par le
gouvernement
d'un côté on voit bien quand on examine
les chiffres que nous approchons pour ce
qui concerne
la gravité des effets de l'épidémie des
chiffres que nous n'avions pas connu
depuis très longtemps et qui certes sont
encore inférieurs aux chiffres
que nous avons connu lors du pic de
contamination du printemps 2021 mais qui
s'en rapproche nous avons près de 4000
personnes qui sont entrées en service de
soins critiques nous avons connu des
périodes avec jusqu'à six mille six
cents personnes entrées en soins
critiques ça veut tout de même dire que
les informations qu'ils aux calories
heureux de se raccrocher et qui consiste
à penser que le virus au micron
et d'une moindre gravité doivent être
corrigés par le nombre des
contaminations parce que moins grave
certes mais plus de personnes
contaminées ça veut dire quand même même
si la proportion de cas graves est plus
faible que le nombre de cas graves en
valeur absolue ne cesse d'augmenter donc
il ya là une préoccupation moi je pense
que ça n'est pas le pass vaccinale qui
va résoudre ce problème mais je me
tourne vers le ministre en lui disant
nous surveillerons avec vous ce qui va
se passer dans les jours à venir je
n'exclus pas que vous soyez obligé de
revenir voir le parlement ou de
mobiliser des instruments d'action que
vous avez déjà à votre disposition dans
le cadre de la loi sur l'urgence
sanitaire parce que il faut bien dire
les chiffres qui attestent de la gravité
de la maladie pour beaucoup de
compatriotes sont bien là et ce entre
occupants mais si ça n'est pas le pass
vaccinale qui résout cette question ça
ne veut pas dire qu'il n'a pas d'intérêt
sanitaires j'entends dire bah oui il ne
freine pas les contaminations sans doute
ne les fera t-il pas comme on voudrait
qu'ils les freinages mais il y a tout de
même un autre intérêt sanitaires c'est
tout simplement la protection de
personnes qui sont
infiniment plus exposés à des formes
graves à des formes longue de co vide on
ne peut pas nier que ces personnes si
elle n'adopte pas un régime de vie pour
se protéger doivent être protégés
peut-être malgré elle en faisant en
sorte qu'elles n'aillent pas dans des
lieux où les risques de contamination
sont pour elle très important il ne
s'agit pas de se poser la question de
savoir si elles vont contaminer les
autres ceux qui seront protégés mais de
savoir si ceux qui sont protégés ne vont
pas les contaminer elle
est c'est parce que on veut faire en
sorte que cette population c'est
l'équivalent de la population du
danemark 5 millions de personnes ça
n'est pas négligeable
si on veut en faire en se faire en sorte
que cette population soit protégée alors
il faut en notre âme et conscience se
poser la question de ce pass vaccinale
moi j ai répondu pour mon propre compte
en faisant les propositions que j'ai
faites qui ont été adoptés par la
commission des lois je crois que pour
limiter que soient les effets de ce pass
vaccinale il a une valeur ajoutée par
rapport au dispositif actuel c'est la
raison pour laquelle la commission sur
ma proposition a rejeté ces amendements
l'avis de la commission est donc bien
défavorable monsieur le président est
monsieur le ministre
mais peut-être faire une réponse un peu
globale sur l'ensemble de ce qui a
beaucoup d'amendements qui vise à
détricoter ou la supprimer ou le base
actional redonner d'abord l'esprit le
rapporteur l'a très bien dit le passé ni
terre on vous demande quelle était
l'utilité du bassin sanitaire
s'il y en avait déjà qu'une allée
factuel 12 5 millions de français qui
ont dit c'est de se faire vacciner
douze mille 5 millions de français qui
ne sont donc plus exposés au risque de
formes graves
12.5 millions de français qui ont été
protégés lorsque la vague a delta a
continué de monter et lorsque la vague
omikron est apparue
vous posez la question du pass
sanitaires et de son impact du fait de
ses 12 points 5 millions de français qui
sont décidés à faire vacciner depuis le
à partir de la mi juillet nous avons
évité un confinement nous avons évité un
grand nombre de malades hospitalisés
supplémentaires
c'est pas une opinion
c'est une c'est factuel ça s'appelle des
statistiques médicales fondées sur le
calcul de risque selon qu'on soit
vaccinée ou non par rapport à
l'exposition au virus
qui va en réanimation aujourd'hui
qui sont les français qui m'ont
réanimation aujourd'hui
des français qui ne sont pas vaccinés
donc plus vous avez de français qui se
vaccinent moins vous avez de français
qui vont en réanimation tous les outils
qui tous les outils qui vise à pousser
les gens se faire vacciner la deuxième
catégorie de personnes qui vont en
réanimation bien que vacciner bien que
les vacciner
monsieur monsieur le sénateur hervé vous
allez voir c'est des maths c'est basique
c'est une règle de trois vous avez
majorité de français en réanimation
aujourd'hui qui sont des patients non
vaccinés alors que vous avez 8 % des
français qui ne sont pas vaccinés fait
une règle de trois vous allez voir le
calcul de risque il est évident vous
êtes toutes les statistiques de tous les
instituts de france qui vous montrent
que vous avez vingt fois moins de
risques dans leur animation si vous êtes
vacciné et à jour que si vous n'êtes pas
vacciné 20 fois moins on peut nier
l'évidence quand c'est 1,2 ou 1,3 quand
c'est 20 fois moins ces puces et 6 à
l'appel pardonnez moi c'était des
statistiques basique basique est avérée
et mondiale est partagé par tous les
comités scientifiques du monde entier
personne ne peut remettre en question si
ça c'est pas une opinion dont on est en
train de parler faut pas confondre
l'opinion et la science
de deuxième catégorie de patients qui
vont en réanimation bien que vacciner
sont des gens qui sont immunodéprimées
si vous allez dans les services de
réanimation de votre territoire de vos
départements respectifs vous verrez il
voulait médecin vous le diront monsieur
là est vacciné mais greffe rénale sousse
immunosuppresseurs un immunosuppresseur
ça fait ce que son nom comme son nom
indique ça supprime la fonction de la
fonctionnalité du système immunitaire
est donc bien que vacciner ces gens là
ne peuvent pas répondre correctement
vaccin est donc fondé cas graves vous
avez aussi pardonnez moi c'est pas la
catégorie la plus fréquente mais elle
existe et parce qu'elles existent j'en
parle systématiquement des femmes
enceintes
qui sont en réanimation parce qu'elles
n'étaient pas vaccinés parce qu'elles
ont eu peur ou parce qu'à un moment
donné
cain le radiateur est enceinte il serait
peut-être attendre parfois même
d'ailleurs des blouses blanches arrive
encore hélas
ce sont les français mais ce sénateur le
je le redis un français 50 ans vacciné
sans immunodépression en réanimation ça
s'appelle une histoire de chasse ça
arrive et c'est très rare c'est très
rare bref vous n'avez pas salutaire
qu'elle servait à 50 poser la question
ça aussi réduit la contagiosité dans les
bars et les restaurants les études du
professeur fontanet vend très bien
montré et donc ça a permis de ne pas
fermer les bars et restaurants à des
moments fatidiques faut poser la
question l'utilité du pentax finale vous
avez déjà un premier exemple de
l'utilité du kazakh synad depuis depuis
que le pass vaccinale a été proposé
comme alain comme étant bientôt adopté
dans la loi nous avons enregistré une
augmentation du nombre de primo
vaccination alors c'est moins
spectaculaire que les 12 millions et
demi de l'été mais pourquoi parce qu'on
s'adresse à une population de 4 et
quelques millions de français mais quand
vous avez vingt ou trente mille de plus
chaque jour par rapport à vent qui sont
vaccinées vous rendez compte que chaque
jour vous réalisez une partie du chemin
qui vous séparait du 100% vaccination
donc ça fonctionne déjà et ça
fonctionnera encore davantage lorsque ce
sera lorsque je serai opérationnel on
peut toujours remettre en question des
mesures et c'est tout à fait normal et
là je joue là dessus contrairement à ce
que je disais tout à l'heure sur
l'affirmation des décades et pas des
français qui vont en réanimation et
c'est sur l'utilité houle ou la
puissance de l'impact de telles ou
telles mesures de gestion et de freinage
il faut rester très humble je noterai
juste que c'est le douzième texte que je
défends devant vous le passez vaccinale
ne marchera pas gelé entendu en parlant
du couvre-feu j'ai entendu en parlant
des jauges j'ai entendu en parlant la
limitation des rassemblements j'ai
entendu en parlant du pass sanitaires
j'ai entendu en parlant des des
fermeture des bars et des restaurants à
chaque fois il ya eu des gens il a eu
des gens pour me dire ça ne marchera pas
où ça n'est pas efficace force est de
constater mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs que la france est l'un des
seuls pays européens aujourd'hui à
maintenir totalement ouvert ces
établissements recevant du public les
bars les restaurants que vous pouvez
vivre beaucoup plus librement que dans
la majorité du territoire européen parce
que le choix que nous avons fait le
président de la république à feu c'est
le choix de la vaccination il n'est pas
unique il ya le choix du télétravail est
une mesure fonctionnel il à l'imitation
des grands rassemblements pour éviter
des supercluster est l'exemple
contamination par chaîne mais
aujourd'hui à l'heure à laquelle je vous
parle et malgré une vague de
contamination sans précédent dans notre
histoire avec des centaines de milliers
de cas positifs chaque jour nous sommes
un pays qui est resté ouvert un pays qui
reste est vivant et qui pardonnez moi de
le dire garantit plus de liberté qu'un
certain nombre de pays qui ont fait des
choix différents et qui aujourd'hui
constate que dans trois heures les
restaurants les bars devront fermer
merci monsieur le ministre
monsieur hervé pour explication de vote
oui monsieur le président je vais voter
ces amendements de suppression de
l'article 1er mai je voulais m'adresser
aux ministres et on lit en reprenant un
article paru sur le site de lutte contre
les sectes news de libération pour lui
dire que aujourd'hui
56% selon les chiffres de la drees qui
dépend de votre ministère monsieur
ministre 56 % des entrées en soins
critiques correspondent à des gens qui
n'ont pas reçu deux doses vaccinales et
qu'en revanche
36% ont reçu deux doses et 6% on a reçu
3 36 de doses
+63 dose ça fait quand même 42% des
personnes admises en réanimation
monsieur le ministre c'est le jeu tient
à la disposition de l'ensemble des
membres du sénat c'est insensé ce
chiffre là si l'on déchiffre de la dre
de l'adresse vous avez raison monsieur
le ministre sur les chiffres on ne veut
pas polémiquer
merci monsieur h à st
merci monsieur le président c'est miss
mes chers collègues je voudrais
intervenir sur ces amendements dire que
je suis d'accord avec kadima dame madame
cohen concernant les personnes qu'il
faut rechercher il ne faut pas les
culpabiliser il faut dialoguer avec eux
et
effectivement on obtient dans la plupart
des cas
l'obtention d'une vaccination donc c'est
pas en les culpabilisant qu'on avance
c'est plutôt le contraire mais je
voudrais citer après monsieur le
rapporteur
citer quelques chiffres qui viennent qui
sont fournies par les professionnels de
santé de la nouvelle aquitaine et bien
sûr en leur science réfère donc
uniquement pour les personnes en soins
critiques ou réanimation
sur
1100 et bien il y en a sept cent
quarante terrain qui ne sont pas
vaccinées du tout il y en a 350 5 sont
vaccinés mais avec une dose récente et
il y en a 40 avec des vaccinés complet
donc je pense que ces chiffres il n'y a
pas besoin de faire de bla bla bla mm
ils disent que la vaccination est
parfaitement efficace merci madame
guillotin
oui mais merci monsieur le président
donc moi je vais je vais voter contre
ces amendements je vais donner jusqu'à
le chevêtre rapide la situation
aujourd'hui du chru de nancy 32 patients
réanimation sur les 32 patients en
réanimation 24 sont des non vaccinés
quatre sont des patients immunodéprimés
ou à plus de six mois de la dose quatre
seulement sont des patients vaccinés à
jour moi ce que je voudrais dire en plus
de ce qui a été dit ces 28 patients non
vaccinés en réanimation c'est pas des
patients qui reste cinq jours comme une
ré assure un infarctus ou des choses
comme ça c'est des patients qui reste
entre trois et six semaines en
réanimation pour lesquels il faut les
changer toutes les 12 heures de position
dont qui bloquent entre guillemets delhi
pendant six semaines et pendant six
semaines eh ben on va bloquer des
interventions pendant six semaines la
personne de 50 ans qui va faire son
infarctus n'aura peut-être pas sa place
en réa et pendant six semaines le
service ne tourne pas alors allez voir
les services d'hans réanimation aller
parler aux soignants à les écouter ce
qu'ils disent ils se plaignent tous les
jours ils n'en peuvent plus de cette
situation
alors oui le pass annie terre a permis
de booster la vaccination si le pass
vaxy le pass vaccinale doit encore en
bout en bout c'est je pense qu'il faut y
aller et moi je suis favorable et quand
on regarde les pays étrangers chez sur
une zone frontalière le luxembourg
aujourd'hui oblige le pass vaccinale
pour le monde du travail et on a une
remobilisation de la vaccination des
français sur le territoire frontalier on
a remobilisé notre population donc moi
je suis plus que favorable et je pense
qu'il faut y aller et arrêter de enfin
voilà de passer à des discussions
de circulation virale ça n'empêche pas
la circulation virale salah diminue
certainement mais en tout cas ça évite
des patients d'aller en réalité
l'essentiel merci chers collègues donc
je mets de voir les quatre amendements
identiques de suppression le 5 914 186
avec deux avis défavorables de la
commission devrait manquer pour
qui est contre
qui s'abstient ils ne sont pas adopté
deux amendements discussion commune de
oui madame apourceau poly merci monsieur
le président monsieur le ministre face
aux retards de la campagne de
vaccination le gouvernement avait décidé
d'abandonner la démarche de prove de
prévention de la vaccination pour
imposer le pass annie terre avec la loi
du 31 mai 2021 se passe sanitaire est
transformée aujourd'hui en passe
vaccinale alors que le pass sanitaire
devait permettre la réduction de la
transmission du virus la cinquième vague
en cours dans notre pays démontre
malheureusement l' inverse avec une
population vaccinée en très grande
majorité
alors que l' oms ne cesse de rappeler
qu'il faut mieux convaincre que
contraindre le gouvernement choisit pour
sa part la contrainte à grands renforts
d' autoritarisme et les propos
malheureusement récents du président
n'ont pas calmé les choses bien au
contraire la méthode choisie revenons à
imposer la vaccination par la contrainte
est contre-productif notre amendement
s'inscrit en porte à faux avec la
politique de santé publique que vous
défendez plus que jamais nous pensons
nous réaffirmons qu'il nous faut une
politique de santé basé sur la
transparence la non stigmatisation quel
est le sens de notre amendement de repli
je vous remercie merci chers collègues
d'amendements 2 me servais
oui bon monsieur le président monsieur
le ministre
remplaçants aux sionistes de la santé
je voudrais d'abord vous dire que c'est
un un moment qui propose une rédaction
nouvelles de l'article 1er et qui
propose de supprimer le pass sanitaires
à faire un petit historique de la sphère
du pass sanitaires d'abord il a été
présenté en décembre 2020 puis retiré
des travaux de l'assemblée nationale
ensuite il a été proposé en début
d'année
2021 pour des grands événements sportifs
il a été élargie puis puype hyper dur et
on est maintenant dans une énième
mouture de ce pass sanitaire qu'on va
appeler parce vaccination va retirer en
fait du du passo sanitaires les tests
pour les non vaccinés et on va leur
interdire d'avoir accès à ce fort de
cette forme de passe je le dis en tant
que vacciner triple dose sans même avoir
attendu d'ailleurs le discours martial
du président de la république du 12
juillet pour avoir lu qu'ovide récemment
j'ai pas de difficulté mois avec la
responsabilité individuelle et
collective que suppose cette pandémie là
où une vraie difficulté c'est avec les
mesures privatives de liberté je les dis
d'ailleurs dans la question préalable
que j'ai déposée et défendu tout à
l'heure je crois vraiment que le risque
fondamental dans notre pays et d'attenté
durablement aux libertés publiques de
soumettre à l'état de santé l'accès à
des lieux pour n'avoir aucun objectif
en matière sanitaire c'est à dire en
matière de contamination
aucun objectif vers de contamination
mais de continuer alors que le conseil
d'état l'avait lavé l'avait écartée dans
son avis d'aller vers une politique de
promotion va carrément je fais partie
des gens qui me félicite que les
françaises savent vacciner mais je
considère que l'utilisation d'un tel
outil sa généralisation le fait qu'ils
durent dans le temps et le fait que
finalement les français s'accoutume à
ceux à ce pas sanitaire c'est vraiment
un risque très important pour la société
française et je propose que nous
supprimions le pas samedi merci chers
collègues me sera porteur
pour les mêmes raisons que celles que
j'ai énoncé tout à leur avis défavorable
de la commission pour les deux
amendements et monsieur le ministre
monsieur le président mon soir bonsoir à
toutes et à tous ça sera également un
avis défavorable la part du gouvernement
sur ces deux amendements
sinon je me revois l'amendement ne
servait oui je voudrais profiter de
votre arrivée monsieur le secrétaire
d'état pour dire que le ministre n'a pas
répondu à l'intervention que j'ai fait
sur les chiffres tout à l'heure je veux
pas être dans une logique de polémique
avec aucun de nos collègues sur les
questions des chiffres libération a
sorti un article remarquable de 7 de sa
division il s'appelle cheikh news qui
lutte contre l'effet que news et qui
reprend sur les la question des chiffres
les chiffres de la drees est-ce du mois
de décembre je vais l'envoyer sur la lgv
aux adresses de sénateur au vous ayez
cet article vous invite à le lire
intégralement et je pense que c'est un
je pense que cet article est extrêmement
bien fait extrêmement bien faite le
trompe peut-être monsieur président
retailleau mais je vous assure que vous
feriez bien de lire monsieur président
retailleau cet article parce qu'il est
extrêmement bien fait et il détaille par
complètement ils démontrent l'effet que
news d'où qu'elles viennent merci chers
collègues mascherano
merci monsieur le président je suis co
auteurs de cet amendement que je vais
évidemment soutenir simplement le dire
depuis le début l'année dernière je
m'étais opposé aux passants étaient
rares certains ont pu dire j'avais des
positions dogmatiques et puis je sens
quand même dans notre pays et dans mon
territoire qui a vécu un événement
malheureux ce week end il ya une enquête
en cours la justice fera la lumière de
toutes circonstances compte 15 % d'une
population d'un petit territoire se
mobilisent alors qu on est vaccinés à
plus de 92% sur mon archipel je pense
que ça doit amener les responsables
publics à réfléchir cet outil n'est pas
adapté à tous les territoires en
l'occurrence sur un territoire insulaire
petit où la cohésion sociale est
importante on est en train de fracturer
un territoire et je lui ai dit à
plusieurs reprises je le répèterai à
nouveau ce soir au préfet qui organise
une nouvelle réunion sur la mise en
oeuvre du passé ni terre sur le
territoire c'est une erreur cet outil je
pense qu'il ya d'autres méthodes pour
inciter les gens à se vacciner c'est le
triple vacciner un triple dose qui peut
en discuter et en parler bien évidemment
je pense que c'est une erreur
fondamentale
je crois qu'on n'a pas forcément perçu
les conséquences au delà de l'aspect
sanitaire je pense qu'à des questions
philosophiques je pense qu'il ya
changement de paradigme dans la société
et je crois que ce mouvement de fond je
l'avais déjà dit notamment pour
l'outre-mer qu'on te parler de
l'obligation vaccinale des personnels
médicaux j'avais dit sur public sénat
que c'était différent de des gilets
jaunes et qu'on aurait nombreuses mme en
outre mer ça n'a pas raté et d'ailleurs
le paradoxe c'est que pour l'outre-mer
pour certains territoires vous avez
accepté à l'assemblée nationale un
report l'entrée en vigueur du pass
sanitaires ou du pass vaccinale dans des
territoires qui ne sont pas suffisamment
vacciner c'est le paradoxe complet d'une
mesure qui était mise en oeuvre et je
demanderai de toute façon s'il passe est
adoptée dont les conditions d'un
l'assemblée par rapport à l'outre-mer à
saint pierre et miquelon qu'il soit
adapté au contexte local tels que ça a
été prévue mais tel que l'amendement
était prévu à l'assemblée c'est dans un
territoire où il n'y a pas suffisamment
de vaccination moi je demanderais y
compris sur un territoire très bien
vacciner parce qu'il n'est pas adapté
forcément au contexte sociologique de
tous les territoires si chaque collègue
monsieur robert
je président
jeune ministre regrette que précédent
ministre soit parti pour ne pas répondre
ces chiffres parce qu'on les chiffres
c'est si un peu comme les lampadaires
pour les alcooliques se sert plus à
soutenir qu'à éclairer
donc je
voterai l'amendement de loïc hervé
en tant que citoyen en tant que
parlementaire en tant que médecin parce
que j'ai quand il avait pas de test on
faisait des scanners des ce qu'on
appelle des scanners low dose et on
disait celui là d'être commis depuis
l'appel coheed j'en ai fait beaucoup
j'en fais encore j'en vois de moins en
moins sur les chiffres ça fait deux ans
que j'entends des mensonges on nous a
dit que le vaccin marchait que le vaccin
empêcher la contamination que le vaccin
empêcher la transmutation
transmission en france nous sommes le
pays le plus vaccinée 91% de vacciner et
ça ne marche pas donc je voterai
l'amendement 2 loïc hervé qui n'est pas
médecin mais qui est plein de sagesse
merci le président ohio
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre je n'ai pas évidemment voter
les amendements de suppression je ne
voterai pas non plus cet amendement le
pass d'accès je vais m'expliquer bien
sûr cher le hic hervé le patac sinal
n'est pas parfait on le sait notamment
vis-à-vis de la transmission mais si on
sait quelque chose quand même et les
chiffres ont un sens c'est qu'il protège
contre les formes graves vous avez fait
allusion à la fameuse enquête de la
drees qui s'est déroulé entre la
mi-novembre et la mi-décembre
tout le monde ici la vue les chiffres
que vous avez données sont exactes mais
vous en tirer de mauvaises conclusions
pourquoi parce que vous avez un chiffre
qui porte sur deux populations de
tailles très différentes ceux qui sont
vaccinées c'est plus de 90 % ceux qui ne
sont pas vaccinés c'est moins de 9% ça
signifie que les mêmes chiffres que vous
avez utilisés donnent en chiffres
absolus qu'il y a neuf fois plus de
risque lorsque vous n'êtes non vaccinés
d'entrée de vous retrouver dans un
service de réanimation que pour la
population en chiffres absolus que pour
la population qui est l vaccinés par
ailleurs j'avais ce matin parce que j'ai
voulu la société française de
réanimateurs et des anesthésistes parce
qu'ils sont eux au moment où on parle
ici en première ligne ils ont fait une
étude sur 165 sites hospitaliers mes
chers collègues je vous rappelle qu'en
france le nombre de départements ces 101
départements et bien c'est 80 % et + 2
non vaccinés qui se retrouvent en soins
critiques et aussi en service de
réanimation
ça signifie que le taux de protection du
vaccin contre les formes graves pas
contre la transmission contre la formule
grave c'est sans doute 93 à 94% moi ce
que j'estime et c'est pour ça que je
voterai avec une règle de
proportionnalité tels que les
rapporteurs vont nous proposer les
amendements je le voterai pourquoi parce
que l'immense avantage c'est que moi je
veux éviter le tri je veux éviter au
maximum les déprogrammations et je veux
éviter au maximum l'encombrement dans le
service de réanimation
merci chers collègues c'est benarroch
c'est le président j'ai l'impression que
nous avons fait d'eux des barres
parallèles et non pas un débat
contradictoire nous avons deux débats
parallèles parce que je comprends très
bien les chiffres qui sont donnés et je
comprends très bien en quoi certains
d'entre nous pensent effectivement à
juste titre d'ailleurs que la
vaccination est un élément indispensable
de la lutte contre la pandémie de co
vide et qu'effectivement nous sommes
aujourd'hui dans une situation en france
où nous ne pouvons que nous louer
d'avoir un grand nombre de gens vaccinés
je comprends parfaitement ça je l'admets
volontiers je partage cette opinion mais
au-delà de cela dans la situation nous
sommes aujourd'hui et non pas dans la
situation où nous étions il ya un an et
demi avec le nombre de vaccinés que nous
avons en france avec le nombre de
personnes aujourd'hui dont on sait
qu'ils ne sont pas vaccinés pour des
raisons que nous ignorons puisque nous
n'avons pas encore la répartition de ces
gens d'en vacciner nous ne savons pas en
fait dans la réalité
combien sont ceux que vous appelez des
antilles vax que
certaines nos collègues voue aux
gémonies ou combien ne sont pas vaccinés
parce que ils n'ont pas eu la
possibilité des lettres ou parce que
c'est très compliqué pour eux de lettres
ou combien ne le sont pas simplement par
négligence nous ne le savons pas nous
savons que les non vaccinés sera qu'un
et ont plus de chances de développer
des formes graves qui les conduira aux
urgences mais ce n'est pas de cela dont
on parle et loïc hervé je ne pense pas
qu'il ait remis en question tout cas où
ce qui nous concerne nous ne le
remettons pas en question nous dit jean
jusque dans la situation où nous nous
trouvons aujourd'hui premièrement il n'y
avait pas d'urgence à faire voter une
nouvelle loi d'urgence sanitaire et que
deuxièmement les alertes que nous avons
lancé depuis un an et demi sur le fait
que petit à petit ses lois d'urgence
sanitaires vont renforcer et le le
situation liberticide de notre pays est
habitué comme une sorte de propagande
comme une grenouille qui est plongé dans
l'eau froide et dont on fait bouillir
petit à petit lot bien entendu
progressivement nous rentrons dans un
type de société dans une société du
contrôle permanent sociale
moufles et déjà d'urgence récurrents e
successives et c'est cela que nous
mettons en application aujourd'hui merci
chers collègues donc je mets aux voix
tout d'abord l'amendement 134 avec deux
avis défavorables qui et pour
qui et contre
qui s'abstient il n'est pas adopté
l'amendement 2 avec deux avis
défavorables qui et pour
qui et contre qui s'abstient il n'est
pas adopté trois amendements discussion
commune de 73 monsieur sûr
que le le président monsieur glisse
chers collègues nous persistons et nous
signons vous savez que nous avons
toujours été ici au sénat très attentifs
à ce qu'ils puissent toujours y avoir
des clauses de revoyure par rapport à la
situation d'urgence sanitaire
et nous avons dit monsieur le ministre
que vraiment nous renvoyer au 31 juillet
ce n'est pas ce n'était pas sérieux
nous considérons après avoir lu
attentivement l'avis du conseil d'état
que dès lors qui existera le pass
vaccinale il est encore plus important
que cette clause de revoyure puisse
avoir lieu avant le 31 juillet en effet
nous l'avons déjà dit tout à l'heure
il est très nécessaire
qu'il y ait des dispositions permettant
de respecter les libertés
et nous devons être vigilants à ce sujet
je pense en particulier aux contrôles
d'identité et à d'autres sujets
par conséquent il nous paraît très juste
de reprendre un amendement que nous
avons déjà vous présenter et qui
j'espère monsieur le rapporteur
suicidera votre intérêt qui consiste à
dire que le 28 février nous aurons
l'occasion de nous réunir afin
d'apprécier la situation je vous
remercie merci chers collègues deux
amendements identiques le 167 ha nam end
à sa
merci monsieur le président est ce
normal de programmer l'intervention
chirurgicale d'une personne vaccinée
atteinte d'un cancer pour accueillir à
sa place une personne vaccinée
contaminés par la commune
spontanément je comprends l'exaspération
face à ce dilemme qui se joue dans nos
hôpitaux mais la réflexion se doit
d'être plus approfondie les personnes
non vaccinées
n'enfreignent aucune loi le fait de
refuser cette vaccination est un droit
la possibilité de se faire soigner est
aussi en droit s'opposer au vaccin peut
paraître irresponsable bien que cela
soit subjective c'est la vie que je
partage pour autant est-ce que
irresponsables n'est plus un citoyen
comme le dit le président de la
république chacun est libre de ses actes
et de ses choix sans risquer de se voir
privé de ses libertés les plus
fondamentales quand ces derniers sont
réalisés dans un cadre légal mais
jusqu'où va la liberté c'est la question
éthique principal
qu'elle sera aussi la prochaine étape
l'interdiction pour les fumeurs de se
faire soigner ou les libertés
conditionnelles par nos choix en matière
de santé un hôpital public en bonne
santé aurait évité ce dilemme ce n'est
pas en vacciner ou autrui un
irresponsable que je mente guillemets de
payer par lapidation de leur liberté
cette politique désastreuse de santé
menées par les gouvernements successifs
face à ses enjeux éthiques le parlement
doit garder la main sur la gestion de la
crise je demande qu'une clause de
revoyure revoyons soit ajouté le 28 le
28 février 2022 pour que nous puissions
juger de la nécessité au monde de la
prorogation des mesures jusqu'au 31
juillet 2022 avant la fin de la session
parlementaire
merci chers collègues le 187e ravier
si monsieur le président permettez moi
de noter quand même le départ précipité
de monsieur le ministre je ne sais pas
quand est ce qu'il aura été le plus
méprisant envers le sénat s'il s'était
lorsqu'il était présent ou s'il
lorsqu'il était si content expliquant
qu'il est absent décidément ça me
perturbe si vous cherchiez une raison
mes chers collègues pour sanctionner le
ministre le renvoyer à ses chères études
vaccinale envoie en voilà une toute
trouvée cet amendement vise à permettre
d'en finir avec l'état d'urgence le 28
février 2022 et non le 31 juillet 2022
avec possibilité de consulter le
parlement le moment venu pour considérer
la situation l'état d'urgence sanitaire
n'a pas vocation à devenir notre régime
juridique permanent laisser courir
pendant sept mois encore sans aucune
possibilité de contrôle s'est accordée
un blanc-seing gouvernement présents
ainsi qu'à celui issu du remaniement
faisant suite à l'élection
présidentielle et dont on ne connaît pas
encore les intentions toutes les mesures
de restriction de liberté de contrôle
doit être encadrée au risque de devenir
permanente a fortiori à la veille
d'échéances électorales majeures
je remarque avec inquiétude un
glissement du droit vers le non droit
une fascination grandissante en faveur
d'une société et tout contrôler je
m'inquiète dans la paresse
intellectuelle qui mène à tout
relativiser des digues de la séparation
des pouvoirs saute le parlement ne peut
se dessaisir de sa compétence de
contrôle du gouvernement j'ai bien
compris par les votes successifs de la
présentation ce que vous cachez votre
proximité idéologique avec le
gouvernement derrière les comptes des
circonvolutions juridique mais ici
comment pouvez vous accepter monsieur le
rapporteur de la majorité de droite que
nous continuons notre régime hybride
d'état d'urgence pérenniser en laissant
filer cet état d'urgence vous acceptez
d'endormir le parlement dans un véhicule
dont le pilote continue de rouler à
tombeau
r pilote élyséen dont la pensée peu
complexe en 2016 refuser la déchéance de
nationalité pour les auteurs d'actes
terroristes au prétexte qu'on ne traite
pas le mal an l'expulsion de la
communauté nationale mais qui vendent
aujourd'hui la déchéance de citoyenneté
pour les non vaccinés pourtant l'article
premier de la constitution qui régit
notre pays dispose que la france assure
l'égalité
devant les citoyens
courte une courte france dans son
article 5 le président de la république
veille au respect de la constitution
entre cette volonté de fracture et
d'unité nationale j'en appelle à la
responsabilité historique de
l'opposition merci monsieur le prix mais
aussi cher collègue monsieur le
rapporteur
merci monsieur le président j'ai vu un
peu de malice dans le propos tout à
l'heure de notre collègue jean pierre
sueur qui a semblé rappeler que c'est
moi même dans le texte que nous avons
votée en novembre dernier qui avait
introduit la date du 28 février comme
une échéance pour que le parlement se
prononce de nouveau sur le maintien du
régime de l'état d'urgence sanitaire et
de tous les instruments de gestion de la
crise sanitaire mais justement j'ai
obtenu d'une certaine façon mieux que ce
que ge envisageait à l'époque puisque
nous débattons aujourd'hui au mois de
janvier et non pas au mois de février
sur l'adaptation de ce régime à
l'initiative du gouvernement lui-même
qui a bien dû face à l'évolution de la
crise sanitaire se ranger aux arguments
que nous avions avancé au mois de
novembre c'est à dire on ne peut pas
gérer cette crise sans le vote de la loi
par le parlement alors une fois que je
dis cela je me pose la question si nous
devions nous prononcer avant le 28
février pour prolonger les instruments
d'action donné au gouvernement pour
lutter contre la crise il faudrait que
dans quinze jours le gouvernement nous
présente un nouveau projet de loi ça me
paraît un peu court et pas très réaliste
alors j'ai essayé d'imaginer j'ai
proposé à la commission des lois qu'il a
accepté un système alternatif que je
crois finalement plus efficace que
l'inscription d'une date dans la loi
comme celle du 28 février proposée par
ces trois amendements ce mécanisme
compte east à m au moment même où nous
le créons le pass vaccinale en voie
d'extinction en déterminant dans la loi
des critères liés à la gravité de
l'épidémie qui quand ils seraient
réunies favorablement réuni entraînerait
nécessairement là
l'abrogation du pass sanitaires là où il
serait lui passe vaccinale là où il
serait appliquée il me semble que ce
dispositif peut être un peu créatif a
pour lui l'adaptation à la réalité de la
situation sanitaire et ne laisse pas les
mains libres au gouvernement c'est bien
notre objectif pour maintenir le pass
vaccinale si les raisons de son maintien
n'existait plus sur le plan sanitaire
donc je vais vous donner un avis
défavorable tout en entrant avec vous
dans le même dans les mêmes
considérations dans les mêmes objectifs
qui sont que le parlement doit garder la
main sur l'utilisation de moyens
dérogatoire au droit commun qui
restreignent les libertés des français
et avec les propositions que nous avons
adoptée en commission nous gardons la
main nous n'avons donc pas besoin de
mettre dans la loi cette échéance du 28
février qui est trop rapprochée genre à
porter monsieur le ministre
le président écoute et je ne reviendrai
pas à ce stade sur la créativité du
rapporteur qui n'évoquait lui-même sont
l'occasion d'y revenir et sur les
critères je souhaite mettre en oeuvre
pour instaurer un régime de sortie de ce
que vous allez adopter mais simplement
le rejoindre effectivement pour dire
qu'il n'ya pas évidemment pas d'abus
d'abus d'autorité il ya juste une
possibilité qui est donné au
gouvernement de prendre un certain
nombre de mesures dans ce dans ce
cadre-là en respectant évidemment une
stricte nécessité une stricte
proportionnalité des mesures qui sont à
apprendre en fonction de l'évolution de
la situation sanitaire une obligation
qui pèse sur le premier ministre quand
la situation s'améliore le point en
sortir et effectivement la date est bien
trop rapprochée de façon très concrète
comme l'évoqué le rapporteur pour
envisager
avant c'est cette faculté je le répète
donné au gouvernement qui n'a pas les
mains totalement libres je crois que le
certain nombre de dispositifs qui au fur
des mesures et à mesure des textes ont
été mises en oeuvre afin que le
parlement puisse contrôler le
gouvernement dans le cadre de l'exercice
de ces deux c'est de ces dispositions
mais en tout cas nous serions amenés à
revenir vers vous dit si dans les 15
jours pour vous proposer un nouveau
texte si cette date du 28 février devait
être retenu vous proposons donc de
rester sur celle initialement prévue du
31 juillet donc j'émets un avis au nom
du gouvernement défavorable sur ces deux
amendements merci monsieur le ministre
donc je mets le voilà maintenant 73 avec
deux avis défavorables qui pour
qui et contre
qui s'abstient il n'est pas adoptée même
vote pour 167 même va-t-il n'est pas
adoptée même vote pour 187 il n'est pas
adopté nous passons à trois amendements
identiques de 60 de monsieur pieds noirs
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues dans la
lutte collective contre ce fichu virus
responsable de lakovic 19 on l'y a dans
ce texte de loi le on l'a bien compris
un certain nombre de mesures plus ou
moins contraignantes je veux savoir ce à
l'occasion de cet amendement un message
à renforcer un message à l'endroit de
nos concitoyens pour renforcer les
gestes qu'ils évitent la propagation de
ce de cette épidémie et puis je pense
qu'on doit collectivement aussi prendre
des mesures pour encourager des
dispositions dans certaines certaines
structures pour éviter cette propagation
et c'est cet amendement qui propose aux
responsables d'établissements recevant
du public et aux responsables de
sociétés de transport quel public ou
privé d'investir 2 d'investir dans des
solutions de traitement de l'air pour
éviter la propagation de ce virus est
l'objet de cet amendement que je vous
présente merci le 72e vaugrenard
oui merci monsieur le président monsieur
le ministre c'est un amendement
identique donc je vais pas rallonger le
propos ou simplement si ça peut
apparaître un amendement de détails il a
son importance il suffit nous le faisons
probablement régulièrement les uns les
autres d'être dans le train dans un car
dans un bus ou dans le métro on voit
bien qu'à des problèmes d'aération qui
sont difficiles techniquement à mettre
en oeuvre l'objet de cet amendement
c'est encourager effectivement le
renouvellement de l'air et des surfaces
et le lavage des surfaces dans ses
transports en commun merci chers
collègues 180 identique monsieur blanc
défendu monsieur le rapporteur
le président je préférerais que ces
amendements soient retirés parce qu'ils
n'ont pas une très grande portée et
législatives et puis elle porte sur des
questions qu'il est difficile d'
approfondir sur la base d'un amendement
au sein de cet hémicycle
est il pertinent de faire un amendement
pour qu'il y ait une campagne de
communication sur les instruments qui
devraient être
utilisés en matière de traitement de
l'air des surfaces et s'est adapté pour
le transport sûrement que oui mais ça
doit être pertinent aussi dans d'autres
domaines de l'action publique alors
je vais demander aux auteurs de cet
amendement
si le gouvernement leur donne des
explications satisfaisantes sur qu'il a
entrepris de bien vouloir retirer leurs
amendements et puis sinon
comme j'ai bon coeur je m'en remettrai à
la sagesse
ministre il sombre et très sinon
défavorable pour les mêmes raisons qui
évoqué par le rapporteur autret cindy
fabre âme
monsieur pie noir il est maintenu
ce président merci j'ai écouté les
explications très convaincante du du
rapporteur philippe bas et il a lui-même
bien compris l'objet de cet amendement
qui vise à interpeller encourager les
sociétés notamment les sociétés de
transport public ou privé parce qu'il ya
une vraie problématique sur le
traitement de l'air c'est pas
d'aujourd'hui il ya plusieurs mois qu'on
le dit président a taillé aulas évoqué à
plusieurs reprises donc en faisant
confiance confiance parlant à la sagesse
du rapporteur je vais retirer cet
amendement merci le 72
oui je suis désolé j'ai beaucoup entendu
les arguments utilisés par par monsieur
vélib j'entends ces arguments sauf que
vous interveniez mon cher collègue le
gouvernement qui n'a pas répondu sauf à
dire qu'il était simplement d'accord
avec lui avec vous j'aurais souhaité de
la part du gouvernement qu'il y ait un
certain nombre d'engagements pour savoir
si sur le plan technique avait des
possibilités voire plus tard des aides
financières apportées aux organismes de
transport concernées pour savoir si nous
pouvions trouver des solutions quand ya
pas de réponse du gouvernement je
maintiens l'amendement merci 281
retirer donc je vais aux voix
l'amendement 72 avec un avis de sagesse
des commissions un avis de défavorable
du dollar ne manquer pour
qui et contre
qui s'abstient il n'est pas adopté 5
amendements discussions communes 36
monsieur lévy
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre madame et monsieur les
rapporteurs monsieur le président la
commission et de moi mes chers collègues
cet amendement a pour objet d'apporter
plus de clarté de visibilité
il me semble le type de bon sens en ce
qui concerne les georges dans les stades
et les stades le spectacle
en effet depuis le 3 janvier dernier il
ya des gens rejet maximal qui ont été
mises en place par le gouvernement donc
de 5000 spectateurs pour les stades et
de 2000 pour les seuls du spectacle en
d'autres termes cela veut dire qu'au
parc des princes il est possible
d'accueillir cinq mille spectateurs pour
une capacité de 58 places et à paris la
défense arena stade du racing 92 2000
spectateurs pour 30000 places car elle
est considérée comme une salle de
spectacle dans le même temps le stade de
5000 places pourra faire le plein tout
comme une salle de spectacles de 2000
personnes où est la cohérence dans cette
décision un amendement que je propose
est soutenu par de très nombreux
sénateurs bien inscrire dans le marbre
une règle claire permettant aux clubs
professionnels et aux organisateurs de
spectacles d'avoir de la visibilité en
effet des questions de tenir compte de
la capacité d'accueil en mettant en
place une chose de supplémentaire de 50%
au-delà de la franchise annoncées par le
gouvernement c'est à dire 2000 pour les
stades pour les salles de spectacle et
5000 pour les stades vous conviendrez
qu'accueillir 27000 personnes au parc
des princes où 40 2000 au stade de
france par ailleurs tout vacciner masqué
puisque soumise aux passes vaccinale ne
paraît pas déraisonnable
le spectacle vivant et le monde sportif
professionnel rencontre depuis près de
deux ans des difficultés financières
très importantes et les mécanismes de
compensation mise en place n'ont pas
suffi à les endiguer maintenir des
capacités d'accueil aussi faible
conduirait certainement pas très court
terme a achevé certaines de ces
structures c'est la raison pour laquelle
je pense qu'il est très important
d'adapter ce dispositif existant et je
vous demanderais chers collègues de
voter cet amendement à ses chers
collègues 119 monsieur benarroch
dans le même sens que l'as monaco vient
défendre monsieur lévy effectivement il
nous apparaît plus opportun de permettre
la mise en oeuvre de mesures
d'encadrement des conditions d'accès de
présence dans certains lieux et dans
certain catégorie d'établissements
recevant du public en fonction des
capacités d'accueil des 10
établissements et non pas en valeur
absolue qui ne répond au fait aucun
aucun critère objectif d évitement de la
propagation du virus cette mesure avait
d'ailleurs été adopté par la majorité
présidentielle aux commissions assemblée
nationale elle permet tait d'objectiver
de proportionnelle et georges avant que
le gouvernement ne choisisse de
d'associer à cette recherche capacité
d'accueil
la situation sanitaire et l'ensemble des
caractéristiques non objectivables de
ces établissements je sais que le
rapporteur a essayé de trouver une
écriture de compromis pour ancrer cette
décision mais en fait au vu réellement
de l'objectif d'éviter une propagation
je pense que le la définition de george
lee aux capacités d'accueil de chaque
salle et de chaque stade qui sont bien
connues qui sont des éléments qui sont
facilement vérifiables et connue de
toutes les autorités y compris des
autorités sportives et culturelles et dû
prêter permettrait effectivement
d'obtenir l'objectif qui a cherché avec
le principe de georges
merci 74 me robert oui merci monsieur le
président écouter mes chers collègues
cet amendement va tout à fait dans le
même sens puisqu'il propose encadrer
l'accès aux erp et en prévoyant que les
jauges seront déterminés en tenant
compte de la configuration et de la
capacité d'accueil des établissements
concernés mais de manière
proportionnelle et je crois que c'est là
où notre amendement
est un peu différent de celui du
rapporteur c'est la proportionnalité je
pense qu'en plus cet amendement permet
de prendre en compte la question des
réalités territoriales et laisse
effectivement le pouvoir réglementaire à
l'autorité préfectorale en concertation
avec les élus de définir des seuils
adaptée en fonction de la capacité
d'accueil des établissements concernés
c'est à la fois une mesure de bon sens
mais derrière et je voudrais terminer
par là puisqu'ils valant un même
philosophie que ceux de mes collègues il
y à une question économique parce que la
question des lieux à la fois sportif et
culturel et bien sont fondées aussi sur
des questions économiques et je crois
qu'il ne faut pas surtout dans le
contexte actuel est bien va balayer
cette cette dimension aussi rapidement
donc voilà un peu l'objet de notre
amendement monsieur président de 59
monsieur folio
merci monsieur le président mes chers
collègues
le monde du sport comme le monde de la
culture ont été particulièrement impacté
par cette crise et cela dans un cadre un
petit peu globale et générale tant au
niveau du sport amateur que du sport
professionnel
cet amendement vise par rapport à la
jauge et on a bien entendu les débats
qui ont été ceux au sein de l'assemblée
nationale est la position du
gouvernement visant à dire que tous les
systèmes de georges proportionnelle
serait peut-être compliqué à mettre en
place ce qui reste à discuter et en ce
sens cet amendement vient en complément
des amendements donc qui viennent d'être
défendus à l'instant il vise à apporter
pour tous les événements qui sont à
l'extérieur donc dans les stades où j'ai
vainement culturel une jauge à dix mille
personnes
parce que actuellement nous sommes à
5000 ce chiffre est un chiffre très
subjectif à bien des égards et par
rapport à cela il est nécessaire de
rappeler que pour des personnes qui sont
masquées donc en étant en extérieur la
probabilité de contes animés de
contamination et il somme toute assez
faible au delà de ces éléments cet
amendement vise à poser un enjeu et qui
est un jeu spécifique par rapport au
monde du rugby puisque l'économie du
rugby professionnel repose sur les
spectateurs et non pas comme celui du
football qui repose sur les droits
télévisés et donc dans ce cadre là il
est important de rappeler que par
rapport aux précédentes georges l'état
s'était engagé à des éléments de
compensation et qu'à ce jour il reste
toujours 25 millions qui n'ont pas été
versés donc au rugby professionnel ce
qui pose un certain nombre de problèmes
d' équilibre pour pour les clubs donc au
travers de cet amendement c'est
l'objectif de fixer un certain nombre de
règles qui permetteront d'impacter le
moins possible les clubs de rugby
professionnel ces chers collègues le
sens si ce monsieur guy laroche
on n'a rien à voir avec les quatre
précédents même s'il est étudiée en même
temps puisqu'il parle pas des jauges
enfin bon il a été il a été inclus dans
la même dans la websérie en fait je vous
le rappelle nous l'avions dit et je
pense que chacun d'entre vous l'avez dit
d'ailleurs à l'époque
il était claire et nous l'avons répété
souvent tout ce sable que le un des
problèmes à des défauts inde et des
obstacles en fait à la bonne utilisation
des passes c'est qu'on fait ça donne un
sentiment un faux sentiment de sécurité
je vous rappelle les relâchements des
gestes barrières que nous avions tous
vécu et dont nous avions parlé après le
passé rouillé
un peu l'orateur ça serait bien
merci le président merci ce sentiment
d'ailleurs de fausse sécurité il a été
un peu entretenu par un certain nombre
de déclarations du ministre pas de vous
mais du ministre verra d'abord par la
noce à un moment donné de la fin de
l'obligation du masque en intérieur en
eux rpd la mise en oeuvre du pass
sanitaires on est vite revenu sur cette
mesure où heureusement ensuite des
déclarations un peu trop peu celle du 22
décembre je vous le rappelle on est
basique c'est le ministre qui parle on
veut que quelqu'un qui rentre au resto
se disent les gens qui sont autour de
moi surtout ce protégé donc j'enlève mon
masque je peux manger je risque rien au
micro ou pas au micro c'est une
déclaration du ministre s est pas c'est
pas une invention de ma part d'une fac
nous voilà donc on voit bien qu'un
relâchement des gestes barrières à
partir du groupe à où il ya eu le pass
sanitaires et bateleurs qui aura
relâchement des gestes barrières avec le
pass vaccinale c'est un danger c'est un
danger pour la propagation du virus il
est bien là et si le vaccin toute son
utilité pour éviter les formes graves et
pour permettre une guérison plus sûr et
plus rapide les gestes barrière eux sont
le pilier de la lutte contre les
contagions et doivent être reconnus
comme ceux qu'ils sont essentiels dans
la lutte contre cette pandémie il est
dommage de laisser croire que vacciner
les gens peuvent s'en passer il est
important que cela soit affirmée et
c'est l'objet de notre amendement cher
collègue monsieur le rapporteur
tous ses amendements monsieur le
président ils vont dans le sens une
meilleure sécurité sanitaire donc la
seule question qui se pose c'est est-ce
que les modalités qu'il comporte
sont les plus efficaces sur un plan
strictement opérationnels c'est pas un
débat idéologique que nous allons avoir
il me semble que les décisions prises
par le gouvernement ne sont pas les plus
faciles à expliquer et les plus
pertinentes chiffres de quelques
milliers de personnes applicable quels
que soient la capacité d'accueil une
salle de spectacle ou d'un stade
franchement ça n'a pas grand sens parce
que si vous prenez le stade rennais avec
ses 30 à une 1000 places les bretons le
savent bien et vous le comparez avec le
stade vélodrome avec ses soixante sept
mille places appliquer la même jauge
dans les deux stades et je ne parle même
pas des 80000 places du stade de france
où des 60000 places de lyon ou des 50000
places du parc des princes mais ça n'est
pas la même chose et encore s'il y avait
deux stades de la même dimension
faudrait-il tenir compte du nombre
d'accès parce que c'est au moment où
l'on rentre et où on sort du stade que
les risques de promiscuité sont les plus
grands si bien que il me semble que ça
n'est pas en déplaçant le chiffre d'une
jauge qu'on va régler le problème mais
en fixant dans le texte une règle qui
revient à dire que on doit déterminer
les règles d'accès en fonction des
risques sanitaires lesquels se mesure en
fonction de la promiscuité auquel les
spectateurs vont être exposés et c'est
ce que nous avons essayé de faire à la
commission des lois nous avons écrit que
la réglementation pour l'accès aux
salles de spectacle et au stade est
adapté à la situation sanitaire ça va de
soi et prend en compte les
caractéristiques des établissements
concernés grands ou petits et grands ou
petits c'est moi qu'ils ajoutent
notamment leur configuration
nombre de lieux d'accès pour tenir
compte des dangers concours en faisant
la queue et leur capacité d'accueil
nombre de spectateurs dans les
conditions propres à limiter les risques
de contamination ça ça veut dire dans
les conditions propres à éviter la
promiscuité qui créent des risques de
contamination du coup si vous nous
suivez vous n'accepterez pas ces
amendements non pas parce qu'ils sont
mauvais dans leur principe mais parce
que finalement le plus efficace c'est de
définir la règle dans le texte plutôt
que de donner un chiffre dans le texte
qui sera valable ici et pas là même si
ce chiffre est plus pertinent que les
chiffres retenus par le gouvernement
donc défavorable pour ces amendements à
moins que leurs auteurs veuillent bien
aller les retirer si j'ai réussi à les
convaincre si monsieur le ministre
merci monsieur le président je
commencerai si vous me autorisé par le
dernier le 106 de monsieur benarroch
pour lui dire que celui ci est satisfait
donc lui proposer de le retirer les sept
faits et dans les faits parce que mise
en place d jamais est évidemment dans
l'intention du gouvernement de renoncer
aux gestes barrières qu'il s'agit du
pendu mars où la distanciation des ours
des règles d'hygiène et que par ailleurs
dans là donc ça c'est dans les faits
dans la loi la loi du 31 mai 2021 dans
sa rédaction qui est issue de celle du 5
août 2021 comporte déjà des dispositions
analogues à celles que vous proposez
donc c'est sûr le 106 je vous propose
donc de le retirer si ce n'est de le
défaut ce sera défavorable pardon sur
les autres sur les autres amendements
sera également un avis défavorable de la
part de la part du gouvernement jean
temps j'ai entendu parler notamment dans
l'argumentaire de monsieur lévy de
simplicité des règles sur s'agissant de
son amendement sérieux 36 rectifié
qu'imposer une jauge additionnel de 50 %
dans les stades et salles de spectacles
ayant une capacité d'accueil supérieure
respectivement 5 mille à deux mille
personnes bref tombe de critères soient
forcément gage de simplicité
dans les dispositions que nous mettons
en place est de la même façon
imposer un système proportionnel qui
peut apparaître comme de bon sens comme
étant plus simple là aussi méfions-nous
des apparences cette approche au prorata
se présente comme simple alors qu'elle
peut être éminemment complexe à mettre
en oeuvre en réalité dans les faits
présentant des difficultés de contrôle
et ont exposé à des débats et des
contentieux sur le calcul des surfaces
ou des capacités à apprendre en compte
en second lieu le prorata peut se
révéler inappropriées au regard de la
diversité des configurations des
établissements qui reçoivent du public
qui font que deux établissements sur les
mêmes capacités d'accueil peuvent
présenter des risques sanitaires
différents selon les phase épidémique
selon les caractéristiques des variants
contre lesquelles nous cherchons à
lutter et enfin et surtout peut-être
un prorata imposé en toutes
circonstances ne peut que nuire à la
vraie proportionnalité que je crois nous
recherchons tous c'est d'ailleurs un
rapporteur qui leur rappelait et qui
doit reposer sur une approche plus fine
bien souvent multicritères
contextualiser une approche qui amène au
constat qu'il vaut mieux parfois une
jauge unique simples claires
compréhensibles pour certaines
catégories de rp un moment donné plutôt
qu'à un ratio qui soit sujet à toutes
les controverses en amont ou en aval
dans le cadre d'un contentieux voilà
pour toutes ces raisons le gouvernement
souhaite rester au dispositif
initialement proposé donc porte un avis
défavorable sur ces amendements si
monsieur benarroch
je dois avouer que j'ai pas très bien
compris en fait ce que nous a dit le
ministre à les scores ou nous explique
la proportionnalité c'est compliqué il
faut l'adapter aux configurations et que
donc à partir du moment où il faut
l'adapter aux configurations et à la
capacité c'est plus simple de fixer une
jauge unique sans tenir compte ni des
configurations ni de la capacité donc je
comprends pas ce raisonnement je suis
désolé bon voilà donc je continue à
défendre cet amendement il pourrait pas
de un autre à porter monsieur le
rapporteur je serais d'accord avec vous
à une condition c'est qu'effectivement
le les capacités soient fixés après une
concertation qu'ils aient lieu avec le
préfet avec le préfet avec les clubs
avec les supporteurs avec les élus etc
avant de prendre le décret la mesure or
en tout cas dans mon département je le
regrette mais en général le préfet quand
il nous convoque c'est pas pour nous
demander un avis mais c'est pour nous
informer des décisions qu'il a déjà
prises donc vous auriez raison ou vous
aurait accepté mon autre amendement qui
va arriver après qui dit il faut qu'une
concertation préalable et que les pistes
de décision soit informé par le préfet
auprès des parlementaires je vous aurais
dit vous avez raison mais tel que vous
le défendez je pense que vous avez très
bien défendu nos amendements et non pas
le fait de les rejeter donc je pense qu
prenons en compte votre démonstration
nous ne pouvons que voter les
amendements que nous défendons monsieur
lévis madame robert et moi même donc je
réponde dans ces deux sens et donc je
maintiens les deux amendements et je
vous demande de les voter
merci monsieur basser
le président seul ministre mes chers
collègues j'ai bien écouté notre
rapporteur et j'entends que la
commission a bien pris soin
d'améliorer largement le texte du
gouvernement
eu égard aux décisions absurdes qui ont
été prises jusqu'à présent et chers
collègues pour ceux qui veulent un
exemple je les invite à aller voir les
images d'un match de football qui a eu
lieu pendant les fêtes avec lens lille
où ni vous aviez quelques milliers de
personnes mais ils étaient tous
regroupés ensemble avec l'ensemble du
stade vide car voilà la mesure absurde
de que l'on arrive à prendre lorsque
c'est vrai que ça ne fait que deux ans
maintenant que nous avons le que vides
et qu on ne sait toujours pas gérer des
jauges au gouvernement donc je suis très
heureux que la commission précise les
choses mais je trouve que l'amendement
notre collègue lévy pire enfin de lévis
va vraiment plus encore dans ce sens et
j'aime sa précision c'est pourquoi pour
une fois je ne suivrai pas le rapporteur
et j'espère qu'ils vont en voudra pas je
trouve que cette précision 50% est la
bienvenue car j'entends monsieur le
rapporteur que vous dites que c'est au
moment où il ya les accès aux plus
contaminés mais je vous rassure on se
contamine tout autant en faisant la
queue aux pharmacies pour se faire
tester matin et soir vous avez plus
d'une heure de queue trois heures de
queue dans mon département dans certains
laboratoires pour aller se faire tester
donc c'est une autre façon de faire qu'à
inventer le gouvernement par ces
précisions je pense que nous serons
faire un peu mieux merci monsieur polio
[Applaudissements]
oui monsieur le ministre je suis quand
même assez surpris par votre réponse
vous nous dites on veut quelque chose et
c'est la position du gouvernement de
claire de précis et d'indiscutable vous
n'avait à aucun moment répondu à la
question que je vous ai posé en quoi une
jauge de 10000 c'est claire précise et
est constante et elle pose plus de
problèmes qu une jauge de 5000 je crois
que ça serait intéressant que vous
puissiez nous expliquer comment et je
rejoins ce que vient de dire notre
collègue c'est que souvent il ya des
phénomènes où les personnes sont
regroupées dans des parties de dans des
parties de stade et que par rapport à
cela
je rappelle tous les efforts qui ont été
faits pour répondre aux demandes du
gouvernement par les organisateurs donc
visant à interdire les buvettes visant à
faire de telle sorte que les
hospitalités se fasse à six et non plus
deux bouts donc dans ce cadre là il n'y
a pas de difficultés et vous n'avez pas
non plus répondu à la question que je
vous ai posé par rapport aux précédentes
contraintes qui ont été celles voulues
par le gouvernement au travers de ces
jeunes ça eu des conséquences
économiques pour lesquels le
gouvernement s'était engagé de les
compenser intégralement
aujourd'hui il reste toujours 25
millions d'euros donc qui n'ont pas été
versés au club de rugby la question que
je vous pose monsieur le ministre c'est
de savoir quand allez vous verser ces
sommes là et comment voulez vous qu'on
vous fasse confiance sur nouveau schéma
alors que pour l'ancien je veux dire les
éléments de compensation n'ont pas été
apportées comme il tout comme le
gouvernement s'y était engagé donc ça
nous interpelle par rapport à ça pour
ces raisons monsieur le président je
maintiens mon amendement
il n'y avait pas de demande de retrait
d'ailleurs
madame robert
ou ira rapidement monsieur le ministre
en fait ce que vous avez répondu c'est
exactement ce qui a été répandu à
l'assemblée nationale puisque vous êtes
très bien que c'est un amendement qui
était passé en commission de choses le
premier vous dit ce n'est pas possible
de mettre en oeuvre ce sera compliqué
pouvez vous expliquer pourquoi ce serait
plus compliqué et la deuxième chose que
ce serait source de contentieux si on
prend en compte justement par notre
amendement est d'ailleurs monsieur
ménard roche l'a dit le fait que les
réalités territoriales par le pouvoir
réglementaire et par l'idée de concerter
avec les élus le préfet pour que en
fonction de la configuration et la
capacité d'accueil y ait cette
proportionnalité qui s'applique je pense
qu'au contraire non seulement on prend
en compte les spécificités territoriales
mais on est attentif à la configuration
et à la capacité des lieux et on
applique la proportionnalité des
capacités d'accueil justement en la
matière donc je trouve que ce serait un
complément intéressant à l'amendement
qui a été proposé par le rapporteur et
ça permettrait en tout cas de mettre les
élus dans la boucle et que ceux ci
puissent être également en tout cas
concernés par le sujet toujours merci
c'est cher collègue monsieur lévy
oui monsieur le président désolé
monsieur le rapporteur vous ne m'avez
pas convaincu donc je vais bien sûr
maintenir mon amendement jamie j'ai du
mal à comprendre effectivement pour il
est très compliqué de calculer une jauge
maximale sachant que toutes les tous les
stades ont une capacité d'accueil et
cette proportionnalité les très facile
de la calcul est donc de donner à
l'organisateur du match le nombre de
passes qui peut vendre et c'est aussi
difficile de contrôler le nombre de
places et john finalement que les 2000
personnes je n'avais pas plus de chances
qu'ils soient réellement respecter ou
pas donc cette proportionnalité va venir
justement régler des absurdités
notamment celles que l'on a vues je
rappelle ce qu'a dit jérôme bascher lors
du match le dernier match de lens
puisque les 5000 spectateurs est
exactement dans la même tribune pour des
raisons d'économie puisque quand on met
tous les spectateurs dans une tribune ça
évite de mettre les stadiers dans tout
le stade et comme déjà il perd beaucoup
d'argent le club professionnel il essaye
d'en économiser comme ils peuvent donc
moi je ne comprends pas votre
raisonnement michel ministre donc bien
évidemment cet amendement ainsi que je
lis monsieur de folio viennent essayer
d'aider les clubs professionnels à
perdre moins d'argent possible et
pourquoi faire payer à l'état finalement
ce que sont capables de payer des gens
puisqu'ils veulent voir un match ils
sont vaccinés puisque vous les refuser
l'accès au stade des personnes non
vaccinées donc au stade de france je
pense qu'on peut mettre quarante mille
personnes sans aucune difficulté donc
moi je maintiens cet amendement et
j'espère qu'il sera voté si cher
collègue monsieur guay
merci monsieur le président monsieur mis
ses actes eux mans ce que vient de dire
notre collègue pourquoi en réalité cette
règle de 5000 elle et elle est un peu
absurde parce qu un stade où il ya 40 ou
50 me place si vous avez cinq mille
personnes vous perdez de l'argent vous
avez pas l'hospitalité ni les buvettes
bas qu'est ce que vous faites vous
ouvrez qu'une tribune de 5000 places et
donc il n'y a aucun écart d'un siège sur
deux alors que si on y va sur la
proportionnalité à 50% en 10 ans on
ouvre l'entière entièrement les stades
quelle que soit la capacité qu'elle soit
2 10 20 50 ou 80 milles et on n'impose
qu'un truc une personne ou un groupe de
personnes qui vient ensemble un siège
d'écart et là pour le coup on accompagne
y compris les clubs à passer cette crise
et parce qu'ils perdront évidemment 50 %
des places mais c'est bien plus
compréhensible à mon avis comme ça que
ce que nous imposons 5000 places dans un
stade de 5000 ou 6000 places dans un
stade de 80000 évidemment le stade de 60
ou 80 milles va pas ouvert l'ensemble du
stade et alors qui va perdre beaucoup
beaucoup d'argent donc on devrait là
aussi je crois écouter les clubs et
apprendre de la crise que nous venons de
vivre depuis deux ans pour se dire que
refaire cette jauge de 5000 n'est pas
efficace et n'est pas tenable et conique
ni économiquement et que nous pouvons
proposer autre chose à l'ensemble des
clubs et des supporters à des
supportrices convient aussi de vivre des
moments un peu de solidarité de
fraternité et de divertissement dans
cette période je vous remercie monsieur
à st
présent plus ministre effectivement je
pense que il faut quand même bien sûr
faire attention parce que on a une
contagion
extraordinaire avec le variant micro
mais pense que ce que met en place
oppose mettre en place monsieur lévy
alors peut-être ça peut être amélioré
mais moi je voterai amendements
oui monsieur le président je soutiens
évidemment pleinement la proposition du
sénateur lévis et au delà j'aimerais si
ce n'est aujourd'hui dans les jours qui
viennent que soient clarifiées
effectivement la question a été posée la
situation des clubs professionnels que
ce soit le rugby que ce soit le football
hockey sur glace je pense en particulier
à mon club des hautes-alpes les rapaces
agapes qui se retrouve dans une
situation à cause des restrictions qui
devient catastrophique et il n'y a pas
eu à ce jour les compensations
nécessaires d'accompagnement pour
pouvoir sauvegarder non seulement ces
clubs professionnels mais aussi et
surtout toute la dynamique éducative qui
tourne autour de ces clubs dont je crois
qu'il y est il y à un ciel d'alarmé à la
lancée et j'attends effectivement la
part du gouvernement des réponses dans
les prochains jours si ce n'est ce soir
merci si monsieur le rapporteur
ce président je ne défends pas que le
football ne défend aussi le rugby je
tenais quand même à le dire parce que ma
première intervention n'était pas
complète sur ce point deuxièmement mes
chers collègues je vais exactement dans
votre sens et je me permets de vous
signaler que si vos amendements ont été
adoptés vous vous seriez tirer une balle
dans le pied tout simplement parce que
quand vous dites que la george doit être
proportionnelle à la capacité d'accueil
est que vous ne fixé aucune propension
le gouvernement aura les mâts
entièrement libre il pourra décider 5%
de la capacité d'accueil 10% 15% 20% il
fera juridiquement c'est obligatoire
exactement ce qu'il voudra donc les deux
amendements qui sont ainsi rédigé sont
des amendements qui donne les pleins
voire au gouvernement pour fixer la
jauge dans les stades aussi bien pour le
rugby que pour le foot bal donc je
voudrais vraiment insister sur ce point
si vous vous avez présenté des
amendements qui sont moins contraignant
pour le gouvernement que la position que
je vous ai rappelé tout à l'heure qui
consiste à dire que on doit tenir compte
des risques de promiscuité en fonction
de la configuration et de la capacité
d'accueil du stade en cause quant aux
deux autres amendements qui fixent eux
mêmes une jauge je redis que fixer une
jauge dans la loi c'est une erreur car
ça aboutit nécessairement a traité de la
même façon le stade de rennes et le
stade de france alors qu'ils n'ont pas
la même capacité d'accueil j'insiste
beaucoup sur ce point en vérité quelle
que soit la demande mans que vous
voterez et bien ou que vous ne voterez
pas plutôt ça n'est pas au coeur de
notre discussion législative mais ce que
je vous dis c'est dans l'intérêt même
des porteurs de ces amendements parce
que je voudrais que effectivement leur
intention trouve une traduction
efficiente efficace opérationnel dans la
loi et je trouve que la moins mauvaise
solution c'est quand même ce que nous
avons retenu aller contraignantes pour
le gouvernement merci monsieur le
ministre quelques éléments de réponse
sur le président merci à monsieur
sénateurs folio tout d'abord vous êtes
la voix à la part dont le sénateur
pourquoi pas dix mille efficient d'une
parce que ce n'est pas dans la loi et
pour des raisons exposées notamment par
le rapporteur c'est bien au niveau du
décret qu'aujourd'hui le seuil de 5000 a
été d'éviter et pourquoi pas 15 milles
et puis peut-être demain 2000 en réalité
en fonction de l'évolution de la
situation sanitaire donc ne nous figeons
pas oui mais mais mais même à
l'extérieur mais mais c'est certes l
extérieur en externe vous l'avez dit
vous-même je crois dans votre propos est
incertain d'activités sociales etc forte
heureux qui ont lieu même dans une
enceinte sportive et dans ce cadre là
aussi la circulation du virus a lieu
donc gardons nos rigidifiant pas les
règles de la question de ces pas une
question de laisser une fois encore les
mains libres non c'est simplement être
en capacité de pouvoir s'adapter à la
situation sanitaire madame la sénatrice
vous êtes là pardon madame excusez moi
sur les éléments que vous que vous avez
mis en avant et est fixé des jauges au
prorata en fonction des spécificités de
chaque établissement qui reçoit du
public la surface
sa configuration est très concrètement
ça veut dire quoi projetons nous très
concrètement ça veut dire que le préfet
dans chaque territoire va devoir se
rendre dans chaque établissement qui
reçoit du public va donc on va devoir
donc émettre des centaines de milliers
d'actes individuels pour pour chaque
établissement
mais si monsieur le rapporteur la
réalité la réalité c'est ça mais vous
avez non mais vous vous on peut rester
dans la théorie la réalité c'est que les
préfets vont devoir les se rendre dans
chaque 1er fait pour aller voir quelle
est la surface et puis il va avoir des
discussions sur la surface qu'on doit
prendre en compte mais si c'est ça la
réalité
et comment la configuration et et fait
donc on peut mobiliser si vous voulez
l'aider des centaines de fonctionnaires
préfectoraux et plus encore pour aller
faire ce travail mais la réalité c'est
donc je pense pas que ça soit une
approche qui soit non mais c'est ça la
réalité monsieur benarroch c'est ça la
réalité si on adopte ce genre de
dispositif bon sur les fameuses images
de lille lens ou de lens lille je sais
plus qui était qui recevait c'était lens
bon
après tout c'était un peu surpris
effectivement de voir ses 5000
supporters dans la même tribune soyez
rassurés sur les ont convaincus et vous
le savez
depuis plusieurs mois dans les
protocoles il est inscrit que ce type de
situation ne doit pas arriver et la
ministre des sports a rappelé et
rappellent sans cesse et après cet
événement que dans les protocoles il est
écrit que ce type de configuration et
d'organisations publiques ne doit pas
avoir lieu la ministre des sports l'a
encore rappelé aux exploitants des clubs
et des stades récemment suite à à 7 à
cet événement enfin
quand je râle du sport vous dire quand
même que le miz des sports et les miss
de l'économie sont évidemment attentifs
à soutenir les clubs sportifs notamment
face aux difficultés financières qu'ils
peuvent bonsoir je suis un peu étonné
d'entendre dire que rien n'est fait
comme ça vient d'être dit au bénéfice
des des clubs sportifs je pense que
c'est assez loin de là de la réalité et
enfin rappeler quand même que la
discussion que nous avons pour conclure
un lieu dans le cadre d'une situation
sanitaire ou plus de trois cent mille de
nos concitoyens
sont contaminées chaque jour c'est quand
même ça encore la situation aujourd'hui
est que dans un certain nombre de pays
voisin du nôtre les établissements dont
nous parlons là ils sont fermés
ils sont tout simplement fermé voilà
donc la politique mise en place par le
gouvernement avec les règles qui sont
proposés permettent le maintien de
l'activité permettent de pouvoir
s'adapter au plus près à l'évolution de
la situation sanitaire permettent de
concilier à la fois la sécurité des
français et la poursuite de l'activité
économique des uns et des autres avec le
soutien nécessaire parce que les uns et
les autres auront effectivement un
certain nombre de difficultés voilà
monsieur le président pour ces quelques
éléments devraient encore une demande
d'intervention et puis ensuite on passe
au vote de ces bonus
pourquoi vous attendez pas là c'est bon
j'ai une question est-ce qu'on a évalué
les conséquences de cette décision sur
les clubs sportifs professionnels les
conséquences aujourd'hui un stade à 5000
mettant comme lyon comme lyon psg samedi
commune l'ol a perdu quand on reçoit ce
ministre ce ministre ce ministre quand
on reçoit 5000 personnes sur
l'installation pardon
quand on reçoit 5000 personnes
m
quand on reçoit 5000 personnes sur 70
milles j'ai eu le président de l'ol les
conséquences financières sont énormes
vous savez dans les galeries marchandes
eux chaque week-end il y en a il y en a
cent mille qui rendent ce week-end à
toulon y en a 10 100 1000 qui sont
rentrés sur les riders qui me l'a dit
aujourd'hui nous avons des stades vides
les stades vides qui est malheureusement
nos clubs chaque fois qu'il faut un
match hyper d'argent considérables et ça
peut pas être rattrapé moi je joue
sincèrement je vais voter l'amendement
de monsieur lévy est ce que je le
trouvais juste et et loyal vis-à-vis de
nos clubs professionnels son rugby foot
ou autre ou attendez ou autres
disciplines merci chers collègues donc
je mets nouveau à l'amendement 36 avec
deux avis défavorables de la commission
du gouvernement qui est pour
je vais vous demander de vous lever ceux
qui sont pour se lève c'est plus facile
[Musique]
merci vous pouvez vous asseoir que ceux
qui sont contre se lève
je pense que vous pouvez vous asseoir
[Musique]
que ceux qui s'abstiennent ce rêve
merci merci d'amendement est adopté et
donc il fait tomber
il fait tomber les quatre autres
amendements
voilà donc
gg une information et une mise au point
à faire j'informe le sénat que la
commission mixte paritaire chargée
d'élaborer un texte sur les dispositions
restant en discussion du projet de loi
relatif à la protection des enfants est
parvenu à l'adoption d'un texte commun
et madame jasmin va demander la parole
pour une mise au point
oui je sais de préciser que je me suis
abstenu sur la boutique additionnel au
début du scrutin concernant le scrutin
public donc je me suis abstenu montant
de 3
oui c'est l'amendement 33 tout à l'heure
sur wii tout à fait tout à fait merci de
l'accord acté données de votre mise au
point sera publié au journal officiel et
figura dans la vie politique du scrutin
concerné je vais suspendre la séance
elle sera reprise à 21h45 pour la suite
de l'examen de ce texte
la séance est suspendue
voilà donc pour la première partie de
l'examen du texte sur le pass vaccinale
au sénat la séance a débuté autour de
14h30 il est à 20h11 vous l'avez entendu
la séance reprendra à 21 21h30 il est
une première suspension d'une heure
c'était aux alentours de 16h30 et puis
donc nouvelle suspension de séance à
l'instant pas de panique on reste avec
vous on est tous mobilisés jusqu'à tard
dans la nuit pour suivre avec vous pour
analyser pour commenter et bien l'examen
de ce texte sur le pass vaccinale au
sénat je vous en rappelle les enjeux le
premier le plus important est bien c'est
la transformation du pass sanitaire en
passe vaccinale on a vu qu'ils avaient
clairement d'opposer deux positions il y
avait celle du gouvernement qui estime
que le pass est bien tel qu'il a été
adopté par l'assemblée nationale
préserve nos libertés individuelles et
puis eh bien il ya la position de la
droite et du centre ici au sénat qui
est-il et bien qu'il faut
le encadré se passe vaccinale qui doit
entrer en vigueur la semaine prochaine
selon les promesses du gouvernement on
va continuer bien sûr à suivre l'examen
notamment des articles de ce premier
article de loi qui donc n'a pas été
complètement achevés ce sera à 21h30
vous retrouverez quentin calme est en
salle des conférences et puis on vous
accompagnera tout au bout de la nuit
voilà c'est la fin de cette émission
restez avec nous on se retrouve donc à
21h30 pour la suite de l'examen de ce
texte sur le pass vaccinale au sénat